e
it was
huge sorry so it being 10:30 uh we'll
open the division 2 finance committee
meeting and welcome folks from fish and
yourselves there we go thank you very
much so good morning uh I'm Stephanie
Simi I'm the executive director for New
Hampshire fishing game um literally just
under 90 days in this
role uh so what we'll be presenting
today I did not necessarily have a part
A Part in participating and developing
our budget for our agency but uh I do
have with me our business division Chief
Kathy Lebon and she worked very closely
with the former director and our senior
staff uh to develop the agency's budget
request and although I'm getting caught
up I think she's probably the better
person to answer more detailed questions
um with that being said though if you
don't mind I'd like to uh before I turn
it over to her I'd like to go ahead and
provide a brief introduction um our
agency is mandated as the Guardians of
the state Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources um our mission is to conserve
uh manage the and protect the resources
their habitats inform the public and
provide educational opportunities for
the public as well as provide
recreational opportunities for the
public to appreciate the diverse
resources of New Hampshire these natural
resources of course enrich our lives and
support New Hampshire's economy um our
well-being of our citizens is often
directly connected to getting outdoors
and enjoying and experiencing
nature as I'm sure you're aware um our
opportunities are are becoming more and
more uh I guess uh requested and a
division uh people are trying to be uh
utilize more diverse re resources uh
these natural resources of course like I
said Ure enrich our lives and I'm sure
you're aware we are facing new
challenges as we're trying to meet the
demands and increasing pressure on our
Fish Wildlife and natural resources uh
we're facing issues Across the Nation
and particularly in the Northeast with
disease uh climate resilience declining
species and populations and habitat
changes um all of these of course when I
say habitat changes I mean land air and
water we are facing a variety of these
factors and and as an agency mandated to
work on these species and work on these
habitats we must monitor we must study
we must manage these uh to ensure the
sustainability of our Fish Wildlife
Marine Resources for not just their
existence but the enjoyment of our
residents and the enrichment of our
economy our core functions as an agency
are primarily funded through hunting and
fishing license sales we've built a
strong relationship with partnering
agencies and stakeholders which some of
you are very familiar with this was
Illustrated in the final report of the
committee of the committee to study fish
and game department funding and
Partnerships which was released November
1st thank you representative for
that um through those Partnerships we've
been able to leverage some of the
increasing demands but certainly not all
uh we realize that we're working
diligently to look for other options but
on average across the northeastern fish
and wildlife agencies 70% of the
dedicated Revenue um is generated
through the licensed sales and through
federal grants uh the remaining 30% is
through other sources and this is of
course the northeastern region um
dedicated General funds permit fees
specialty stamps and Lottery there's a
plethora of other ideas that other
states have been using um and we're
exploring some of those fortunately for
us in New Hampshire the public interest
and desire for fish and wildlife and
Marine Resources continues to grow uh
unfortunately like I said earlier the
needs and responsibilities and the cost
of doing business also continue to grow
um as New Hampshire's population
increases the pressure on our natural
resources increase and I've walked into
an agency and I have discovered that we
have very very skilled and dedicated
staff in this agency I've worked in many
other agencies and I will say this
agency is filled with I think some of
the most dedicated people I've seen the
staff continue to work and think outside
of the box they're looking for ways to
improve our efficiencies build
collaborative relationships and utilize
other other funding sources just outside
of the standard federal grants and
matching we recognize efficiency is
essential particularly in this time uh
so we also continue to maximize every
opportunity and seek to generate uh use
of matching funds where available we're
in the process of reviewing and
streamlining several of our processes
internal processes programs we're
intensifying our collaborative work with
other agencies I've been really
headstrong on ensuring that we're
coordinating with other agencies and uh
we're also reviewing our current
Staffing models and assessing our
long-standing self-funded approach and
seeking ways to enhance the agency's
ability to generate Revenue the ficient
game department is marking 160 years in
existence I can't say that I've been
here that whole time but I'm really
proud of the fact that it's reaching 160
years uh we manage over 140 boat ramps
over 64,000 Acres of Wildlife Management
areas conservation easements we host
hunting and engling and outdoor
education programs uh we survey and
manage Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources for long-term viability as
well as the recreational opportunity we
work with private land owners to enhance
their Landscapes and provide
opportunities for recreation to the
public we have one of the finest if not
one if not the finest conservation law
enforcement programs in the nation it's
recognized nationally
and as a new director I will continue to
support the need and examine alternative
approaches for Revenue sources although
I am going to be honest I'm realistic in
knowing that we aren't likely to uh fill
the entire Gap without your
support the uh agency itself we we're
operating on a fairly tight budget um as
I arrived here I realized there were
quite a few critical needs that I had
not anticipated um we have a critical
need for permanency of our uh much
needed environmental review staff which
were currently under they're currently
funded under arpa we have extensive
infrastructure and Technology
modernization needs um one of my primary
objectives this year is to try to
improve our it and our
technology we did meet the 4% decrease
requested however if there are further
Financial cuts to uh our funding and no
additional support through unrestricted
or general funds or even new innovative
ways we are likely going to need to
review and cut some Services as a new
director this this hurts my heart I I
don't want to uh do this as an agency
mandated to serve the public and our
natural resources reducing Services is
very concerning and will result in
collateral and direct negative impacts
not just to our natural resources and
our economy but but to the public who
want to utilize and and value these
Resources with that being said I I thank
you for your time and thank you for your
support and your assistance as we work
through this I will turn it over to
Kathy and she'll be able to get into the
details with you thank you very much
before you before you start yes um I'd
like to ask that in the future you
please provide an electronic version of
your presentation at least a day ahead
of time absolutely sir I'm I'm new to
this so I apologize if I've made a
misstep here I'll certainly provide you
a copy if you'd like I kind of add lib a
little bit but I can give you you can
add lib all you want but we just
appreciate having a preview of what's
coming I I'll I'll send I'll send it out
should I send it to you I'll yes okay
thank you I apologize for that problem
thank
you thank you director good morning I am
Kathy leonti chief of the business
Division and this is my 11th budget
submission for the New Hampshire fishing
game department so I've been in this
role for a very long period of
time well I'm going to speak to
developing the budget in some specifics
of that while we were in the development
of the budget we were able to meet the
governor's general fund
targets however we will we were not able
to meet the governor's targets for the
use of fishing game funds to do so would
have meant considerable cuts to programs
and services the budget director allowed
us to utilize unrestricted fishing game
funds to create this banal budget and
doing that it we only have approximately
looking at the um um financial statement
approximately
$100,000 remaining in the fishing game
fund at the end of this
bium uh um I'm
sorry so each year this budget uses
greater than $18 million in fishing game
funds to sustain our programs and our
staff
however our unrestricted Revenue
expectation is only approximately $14
million leaving a deficit of over $4
million in each year hence that's why we
use a surplus to get through this budget
we currently have
193 full-time employees five of which
are unfunded and remain unfunded in the
2627 banial budget request we do have a
small small amount of General funds
within this budget it comprises
approximately
3.5% of our entire overall
Appropriations each
year when we come before you after the
governor's budget is released I'm sure
that we will have more indepth
discussions and certainly if you have
any questions relative to our agency
budget submission I would be more than
questions that's representative Murray
go ahead and you just you can just go
ahead you don't need to you don't need
to keep asking me just go ahead and run
the run the list all right um let's see
easy one first what's the most impactful
disease that you're dealing with and
what does it take to
um deal with that disease well right now
there're two primary obviously we're
trying to prevent the um influx of uh oh
my gosh just chronic wasting thank you
chronic wasting
disease chronic wasting it's in ulates
particularly dear um and they just
actually had some new sightings in
Southeastern us which is unfortunate but
we've been successful in minimizing the
invasion of that I'll say Invasion
because it's a disease and we don't want
it coming in so we spend a lot of time
time and and effort ensuring that we're
protecting our our ulate herd and
testing for the disease to ensure that's
it's not here the other is hemorrhagic
disease which is common in in rabbits
and hairs and we also do testing uh for
well um about the the hike Safe program
I'm thinking in particular of it well it
seems to me you can correct me if I'm
wrong um there have been an I know this
is also going to spill over into safety
um some serious rescues and several
quite a few death it seems like more
deaths than usual um a lot of these
people are totally unprepared they're
not listening to what it takes to hike
in the in the whites um I have sort of
two questions one is um there was the
fellow who broke into the snow cat with
his dog and um was rescued and took off
this was someone who's totally
unprepared and there are all sorts of
things about save The Dog leave the kid
behind um how do you track this person
down cuz it sound like he kind of left
in a rush track him down because this is
certainly someone who should have paid
for his
rescue yeah I don't know how do you know
how Colonel manages that our Colonel um
Colonel Jordan would be able to answer
that we could get you an answer how what
he does and what the procedure is for
that I don't know exactly what they do I
know they worked collaboratively with
the uh ntion the federal system up there
because they were actually contact
through them and then they worked with
the local enforcement but I don't know
the exact procedure we'll get back to
you on that one yeah the other one there
was a a well um an experienced hiker who
um you know called out for help and he
just could not make it but he was one
who was totally well prepared um can you
with regards to some of that can you
speak to the um what the hike Safe
program um is that still like a $35 is
that something that could go up because
um we have ours um and I'm wondering has
that program grown because it seems like
a really fabulous program the hike safe
program has gone well beyond anybody's
expectations when it was first um put
out there it's $25 for an individual $35
for a family we anticipated at the onset
of that that we might get around
$100,000 a year it has tripled we we we
now receive over $300,000 per year for
that voluntary hike Safe program it has
been extremely successful for the
Department are out ofate people
encouraged to get this how do they know
that they should do this we do a
significant amount of advertising for
the hike safe card and to hike
responsive
responsibly to be upfront as well I just
had a conversation with Taylor Caswell
and we talked about how we could promote
this further and a couple of other
factors with our agency through his his
agency
um many of the people who end up in
distress honestly are from out of state
and just not familiar with the
ruggedness of the terrain and and the
conditions that change so quickly up
there of course they are
right of course of
course representative Pap thank you Mr
chairman hi um thank you for being here
I appreciate the willingness of my
colleague to let me jump in in the
middle of her question it's just a
related topic where it would make sense
to talk about them at the same time one
of the things that we were talking in
the committee that you referred to
earlier was a similar program for
boating which obviously would present
different logistical challenges and I
was curious to hear any thoughts you may
have on that just because it ties
straight into what my colleague was
talking
about I think you mentioned some of the
logistical challenges those are they're
pretty they're not just um surface
challenges they're they're rather deep
and complex and so working through that
process will take time I'm not sure that
um there's a couple of agencies that
would be involved obviously uh you
probably are familiar with that I'm sure
you guys had greater depth conversations
about that topic um it's certainly not
off the table I'm not saying that it's
off the table right now I'm I'm
considering all factions and all all
ideas um but other than that we have not
we have not I've only 90 days here we
have not sat down to say hey we're going
to go forward with this we do have a
long list um my staff continue to bring
ideas and we'll be meeting as a senior
staff to start going through that list
and looking at ways we might generate
more
Revenue representative Murray sorry
continue please oh I should have turned
this up thank you um during Co you had a
boon in licenses seems like everybody
was out fishing and hunting and then it
dropped down after Co where are you on
kind of that curve uh with licenses have
that come back are you seeing an
increase in licenses we we had yeah I am
on we had a couple of years
um 20 and 21 calendar year 20 and 21
were very high looking at the scale it
went way up we have now leveled off to
the same dollars approximately where we
were prior to
covid and and if I may that's um fairly
common Across the Nation with the fish
and wildlife agencies I've spoken with
some of my counterparts in other states
and they're seeing a similar Trend okay
did I understand you said you had five
unfunded
employees correct unfilled and unfunded
they're unfilled as well okay so that
was oh yeah they have to be unfilled
they're unfunded when you said that I
thought I must be mishearing something
here so thank you for that that was easy
um the moose population um how you
seeing that continue to decline I mean
we don't have moose in the southern part
of the State anymore and I wondered this
seems seems different from the problem
that the deer have with the ulet with
the Moose it's the tick the Moose is
it's a very different situation right
now we have an ongoing research project
that is looking at uh assessing the
population and and using different
methodologies to gain a population
estimate we should have more of that
soon thank you and I know that you're
new but you know the the elephant in the
room be here all day um how will Trump's
halting of all grants impact you what
programs are impacted with that you
know you want to talk was quite a scare
yesterday we do that yesterday yes um
certainly you know our agency is is
relying on federal funding grants
matches um we did a a cost estimate just
if we were to have to survive through
the next five months and Kathy can get
into the details on that if you want to
share how you assessed it the next five
months if we were to have to go without
any federal Grant reimbursement would
cost the department5 to5 A5 million doll
we fund a significant amount of our
funds and most of those federal funds
upwards of 70% of them are for salary
and benefits of the Personnel that work
in those
programs so those people would lose jobs
or would they would you would continue
them
and it depends we have the authority
right your appropriation your budget you
have your Authority what would happen if
we were unable to bring in those Federal
reimbursements it would hit the fishing
game fund so the fishing game fund would
have to make up that deficit and it
would be depleted before we even get to
next year's budget yeah it would be
depleted it would be gone thank you I'm
done I'm
set just one moment um at what rate do
those funds flow in are they just
flowing in on a regular if things are
normal are they coming on a monthly
basis weekly basis quarterly bi-weekly
we draw Down based upon the payroll
payroll thank you um yes representative
D thank you for coming today I have two
questions for you one I I know there's a
bill that's out about disease for bait
in my area a lot of our because we're on
a lake we have a lot of businesses that
sell bait can you please explain to me
what disease is coming in from other
states that we don't already have in our
water I'm confused by it yeah so the
bill I can get you more details from our
Inland Fisheries division Chief however
the bill is um not one that we are
concerned about or not necessarily
supportive of it because we don't see
the ne the need for it at this point um
and I think that we do quite a bit for
monitoring and ensuring that we have
healthy populations of both Fish and
Wildlife Resources okay thank you you're
very welcome second question I live on a
lake I see a lot of boats com in from
other Town other cities and states they
don't have to have a license they can
just come in and because they're
apparently their state doesn't have
licensing is that another way that we
can make Revenue by requiring that those
that are coming in because we have
people at the station to check for you
know plants
um to get some revenue from out of state
we do not oversee boat registrations
that's under the department of
safety and if they come in from another
state they should be registered in that
state that would be a surprise to me
that they are not registered in that
state there a lot of States like Montana
and others that don't have you don't
have to register your boat but it end
ends up being a problem but what I'm
thinking of more is our water and the
contaminants that are going in our water
from our tourists coming in and God I
love our tourists because they pay a lot
of wages here in the Hampshire right but
there must be a revenue stream there
somewhere that um that we can get to
help testing the waters and and
protecting um you know our environment
so just a thought so certainly just I
would this is just my thought that would
be for testing of the water and
monitoring of the water would be the
Department of Environmental Services we
do not do anything like that and the
registrations are through the department
of safety we do not have a hand in that
however our department does receive $5
per registration of every registered vat
here in the state of New Hampshire that
goes into the public boat access program
right and we have um our fishing game
right there in New Durham so I'm always
talking to those people about all of the
things that they need so just trying to
think of another Revenue stream that
might we appreciate that we appreciate
much
representative thank you Mr chair
continue um just one quick clarification
when representative Earth was asking
about the frequency of federal fund draw
Downs MH we were talking about the
federal funds that we received when you
said it was bi-weekly right not the way
you disperse money that you got from the
federal F correct okay so we get them at
the same frequency as we disburs them
more or less yes with a time lapse like
our our federal reimbursements are based
on actual payroll and any other expenses
that are incurred during that two-e
period of time it's all rolled up
together so that reimbursement could
come in two three weeks after the
expenses are incurred yes cool so a
couple of things that I did want to ask
about one that I noticed when I was
looking at your budgets we're talking
about revenues from licenses yes and I
noticed that in previous years the the
department tended to budget a larger
Revenue amount from those licenses than
one would have reasonably estimated from
the trends may I ask you know how do you
project those revenues when you budget
for them because sometimes I would see a
line that's straight we get exactly the
same amount and then the budget for the
revenue was a million
higher any thoughts on that for just
strictly Li es if I recall correctly yes
of course we don't have a presentation
and the numbers in front of us so I have
to count on my memory but that's my
recollection of it and if you don't
necessarily have the answer right now
that's fine but when we come back later
I would appreciate it if we could talk
about that I can absolutely tell you how
I budget for licenses I have the exact
dollar amount in every single
unrestricted Revenue category that has
come in for the past 15 20 years
we have to take into account when there
is a license fee increase that that
would certainly skew those numbers and
being able to average
that I I would be surprised if the
revenue had had a million dooll
difference I I would like to see a
little more detail on that
representative if possible and then I
could provide you a better answer of
course we'll follow up when at the right
time yes I just wanted to give you a
heads up
you know as I told you last fall when
were in the committee I want to make
sure you have plenty of time to prepare
what the committee needs for the
budgeting so that there are no surprises
and uh you know we don't like asking for
stuff at the last moment so yeah please
so could you actually just answer the
question about projection let's say
there's no Revenue increase how do you
budget i a i average actually um and I
have that sheet we had to present Monday
to house ways and means and I had this
in my bag that I carry and I actually
have all of the pockets of unrestricted
Revenue including licenses going all the
way back just for this sheet 2013 but my
spreadsheet has it going certainly much
further back than that so um what I do
to budget those revenues is I look at
the trend
but I also look at as a perfect example
our interest on savings deposits used to
be way up here then it came way down
here and crashed so I had to budget
appropriately for that Trend that was
occurring we saw a huge increase in
interest earnings due to all of the
funds the arpa funds sitting in the uh
State's coffers so we receive a portion
of those the fish and game fund portion
of those interest earnings so I actually
came before house Ways and Means last uh
for the current budget we're in and
recommended that we increase that
because we were going to earn much more
than what had been originally budgeted
so you have to make your tweaks like
that and I assume you do that up and
down you're watching both ways
RBS on hack PHS thank you Mr chair and
just continue through great um I am
thankful that you're here and willing to
answer questions today um I'm just
wondering if you could talk about a
little bit about um gifts that might
come to the fishing game department and
you know what is the process for
accepting those gifts um I'm just
looking for a little background any type
of gifts like a tangible item or a
financial component yeah give me give me
what you know okay want me take that
okay so we are always open to donations
at the department and we have a
dedicated account called the gifts and
donations account which is in the
budgetary area of the office of the
director and back in 2018 we actually
had a gentleman from the state of
Massachusetts who passed away and left
us over $300,000 to be used for
Department operations the majority of
financial gifts coming into the
department have a direction that they go
into someone's putting it to search and
rescue someone's putting it to Aquatic
education or Hunter education if they
come in with just Department operations
then we can use that for broad
Department operations any gift coming
into the department has to be approved
by the fishing Game Commission and any
monetary or tangible gift with a value
of $2500 or over has to go to governor
and Council for approval with a tangible
gift that comes then couple years back
we received a million dooll boat for the
law enforcement division to be used out
on the coast and that was a donated boat
to the department and we brought it in
through the governor and Council process
it's put on our
inventory so with tangible items we do
we receive a lot of tangible items you
might be surprised from snow machines
trailers that big giant
people like the fishing game department
they want to give in some way
yeah you're
welcome you may represent Pap thank you
Mr chairman so again something that
we've talked about last fall but this is
a new setting um I believe you recall
that I told you the story of my daughter
who in June was trying to get a
Trapper's license because she's
interested in wildlife and zoology and
the next opportunity to get a license
was somewhere in September so she gave
up on that because by September she was
in Ohio studying zoology and Wildlife I
also believe you recall my uh
discussions with you about how every
time when I'd like to register to get a
hunter's license and I'm not even a
hunter I'm just trying to go through the
process and give you some money and have
my card all the classes were full and
while a class was added at some point it
promptly filled up too and then it
remained full I also have and this is a
new fact since then since I mentioned
this to a couple of people there are
quite a few other people that came back
to me and expressed the same frustration
about being unable to get a license
because the classes are full and they
fill up and then they are full so given
that the department would get direct
revenue from the new licenses which then
presumably would be renewed most of them
and also Pitman Robertson funds are uh
distributed based on the number of
licensed
Hunters have you given thought to
finding a way to always have a class
open somewhere in the state so we don't
Revenue so yes I've given it thought to
offer more classes I I wouldn't say
necessarily it's to always have a class
open you know every day of the year
that's quite extensive how ever um I've
been working with our public affairs uh
division Chief and we've been talking
about different ways to foster more
Outreach and education efforts which
included extending or expanding our
opportunities for trapping and hunting
education courses uh we do have a
facility the owl Brook facility is a
great facility for Hunter education and
I just got a chance to finally visit
that facility and I was quite impressed
by it and I want to
make sure that we're actually utilizing
it to our maximum because it's it's
quite a lovely facility that we have
it's an honor to have it in our agency
if I make quickly followup if I owl
Brook owl Brook Hunter education center
if I may add that Hunter Ed Trapper Ed
and Aquatic Ed are run very heavily on
volunteers for the department and their
volunteer time is used to match those PR
funds
and when you when you run a program with
volunteers I mean we utilize them as
much as we possibly can we do not have
sufficient Staffing within the
department to be able to offer all of
those courses on our own so we rely
heavily upon volunteers to to assist us
with that yeah that's an excellent point
Kathy and you know to the point of the
volunteers we have equated about
$680,000 worth of volunteer time in the
last year which equates to $1.8 million
in match for us so it's quite an
extensive program it's a it's a
successful effort unfortunately we're
not meeting the demand as I said the
demands are rising right and the cost to
do business is also rising and so it's
trying to find that that middle ground
where we can meet the demand and still
be efficient and and effective in what
we're doing I appreciate your
perspective and just as a quick followup
right I want to clarify that I wasn't
asking obvious for classes to be running
every day it's okay if they run 3 weeks
from now I would feel that I I think
that it would be beneficial to the
department overall to always have some
availability in a class in a few weeks
because again for going Revenue it's not
just the money right we disappoint
people the people who are trying to
serve who get frustrated trust me my kid
wasn't very ecstatic about not being
able to trap legally and I told her you
got to do it by the book I'm not going
to have you go in the Backwoods and just
set a trap hoping nobody finds it right
we don't do that same thing for you know
families of five who all want a license
and there are two spots open and now
what you know and I know that is
difficult trust me we did have those
discussions I appreciate the
difficulties I'm aware of that but at
the end of the
day expenses keep increasing and
revenues don't keep up and it seems that
we really need to focus a lot on every
opportunity possible possible to keep
increasing those revenues so I would
urge you to uh give it you know more
thought and attention because I think
it's an opportunity to ease some of that
you know budget Crunch and if I may uh
I'm good represent
Kelly thank you um my question is when
was the last time that your license fees
increase I believe it was 2008
but I I think it was I think it was
2018 it
was
$10 for the major licenses like a a
plain old hunting license and a fishing
license we did not do a license increase
across the
board the issue with raising our license
fees to meet our expenses ex just to
understand what you're saying the
increase was $10 or the it was increased
to $10 no the increase was $10 for each
type so from what to what sort of thing
well for a fishing was went from 34 to
44 thank you sorry representative Kelly
continue I'm sorry um the the issue with
increasing license fees to keep up with
expenditures is we are already very high
in comparison to our surrounding states
we're either first or second in cost for
our license types and if someone from
Connecticut wants to go North to go
hunting and Maine has a cheaper price
they're going to go to Maine they're not
going to come to New
Hampshire if I may one additional
component to that is is not the license
fees but maybe like the habitat fee for
example the habitat fee was introduced
in 1999 at $250 it remains at
$2.50 for the last 25 years so it hasn't
met the inflation and that's one area
where I think you know we could maybe
consider a different approach to that so
we have a couple of things like that
that we could consider without impacting
the license fees and still keeping our
Fishers and hunters in New
Hampshire just one moment so would you
make a recommendation not right now
necessarily but to to us regarding what
you would want to possibly do with a
habitat fee give us give us some ideas
there thank you representative Kelly I'm
sorry that was that was what I was going
to ask but if there are other things
similar to that can you provide a list
absolutely do you want to keep
going yeah go ahead thank you Mr chair
so one question that again probably we
won't get into a detailed answer now but
at least I'd like to get a head start on
it
is your budget seems to have bumped a
bit in the recent years right
and I'm already aware of the whole 10%
rise for all state state employees part
right so that's a known issue and I'm
sure that since we discussed that uh two
years ago everybody on the committee is
familiar with the fact that you know
that was a raise needy to keep up with
inflation and you have a challenge with
the revenues not necessarily keeping up
got that but what else you know hit that
budget to um increase it because it
seems to have uh grown significantly
recently you know the last year or two
or
three salary and benefits certainly is
the major components and as well as
other agencies salary and benefits have
gone up so our transfer to
doit increases substantially to pay for
their salary and benefit increase our
transfer over to das increases
substantially to pay for their salary
and benefit increase so it's not just a
salary and benefit increase for our
employees it's for other state agency
employees as well thank you and for the
benefit of everybody else because I know
we talked more about it last fall but
the committee other committee members
haven't heard could you detail a bit
more the nature of the transfers to it
andd just so that everybody has the
background so you know what do you pay
them for and how much generally are they
paid and so on for future meetings or
for right now if you can give something
right now it can also wait until future
meetings whichever way you are more
comfortable I I don't want to you know
put you on the spot but if you have
something now that would be great if you
want to follow up later that's also
perfectly fine well fishing game just
like All State agencies are under the
umbrella of having all it be under the
department of Information Technology and
if you look at budget increases you can
look at the last 10 or 15 years and you
will see how that budget has gone up
support if I may on uh increases outside
of what is the greatest factor here
which we just discussed there are other
increases we are experiencing just
supplies that we need for doing our
business the economy obviously there's
been inflation in the economy and that's
you know we used to pay $2 a fence post
and now we're paying $12 a fence post
those kinds of things that also
escalates our buz budget as an example
shipping cost which we do a significant
amount of shipping we ship out to our
license agents we we have a lot of
40% and certainly supplies
utilities we have we have six fish
hatcheries four Regional Offices two
education C centers I cannot even begin
to describe the volume of electric bills
that we have oil bills that we have and
all of those items have gone up
substantially just like they have in our
lives just one moment so what is it
you're shipping you shipping you have so
much shipping we have a a lot of
shipping we ship our all of our
regulations and digest out to our
licensing agents I just paid a bill of
over $3,000 to FedEx for the new um
hunting digest or licensed digest yeah
uh I I would have a whole list so have
you
considered dropping the paper and
getting more electronic for your
training stuff and all that well you are
seeing my here sir I would love to do
that we to be honest with you our agency
is behind the times on our technology
and that's where we really need to have
some support and be able to work with
doit and get us up to speed I I have
regions that are not connected to the
state server and that is not conducive
to doing business well no so that's one
of my priorities is working on
technology and innovation of how we run
our systems great so again when you come
before us please let talk about that and
tell us what's going on there and what
could how you think you could improve in
that area and what support you need to
do that absolutely thank you
representative Papi thank you and again
to rehash something that we spoke about
in the fall which uh I told you that
will you know come up during the budget
meetings um we spoke a lot when we
talked about the need for increased
Revenue about the um
responsibilities for fish and game that
were not original in your statute but
have been added over time and I believe
the statements from the agency at the
time were that we keep giving you new
responsibilities but we don't give you
the funding for it and we discussed
about the costs and if I recall
correctly the um estimate that I got in
the last memo I got from you was about
30% of your
costs I would really appreciate as I
asked you then a more detailed break
breakdown and what those obligations are
that we have added to the agency but not
funded because we spoke a lot about the
need to um make sure that the money we
collect from the hunters and Fishers
from your clients go to serve those
people and how we really don't want to
have the hunters pay for search and
rescue for example one of the examples
that comes to mind is again we spoke
about the search and rescue report that
you provide to fiscal committee which
appears to indicate the program is
self-funded and works fine but in our
discussions it was mentioned that we are
only you you guys are only reporting the
direct costs not the indirect costs and
then how would we know you need more
funds if you know according to the
reports we have you don't have a need
there so things like that I would highly
encourage you to make sure you have
detailed data on because they would be
critical in determining you know our
ability to support those programs and to
maybe start working towards addressing
any wrongs the legislator May
legislature may have committed over time
but to address them we got to understand
them understand their impact in detail
yeah so I just for the benefit of the
committee for your own benefit I wanted
you to I want I wanted to remind you
what again we spoke about some months
ago about the need for those details and
lists and you know I would I believe it
was Colonel Jordan Who provided that 30%
figure indeed but as we spoke then I
appreciated the quick effort to give us
something but that is very very um much
not the kind of detail that we expect
right that was a back of the envelope
estimate we appreciated it because it's
the best the colonal could do at the
time but you guys should have much more
detailed on that type of information you
know in order for us to figure out the
right you know amount we can buy budget
yeah okay thank you we do thank you very
much I appreciate that
Insight I should be good for
now representative
Murray thank you Mr chair can I follow
up on something because I got a little
confused um I got the impression from
the discussion that a class is required
for a hunting license I mean there are
lots of any what about there are
experienced Hunters um who have been
hunting all their lives they still have
to take a class every year or how long
does it's a one can you just tell me
it's a Once in a-lifetime class it's
called a hunter education
class and you can take it in another
state and as long as you show proof of
that Hunter education class you do not
have to take it in the state of New
Hampshire but a hunter education class
is a requirement prior to receiving a
hunting
license but then you can renew your
license after that oh yes absolutely
absolutely absolutely yeah you don't
lifetime uh representative
dry can that not be done through Zoom or
do you have to physically have the
person there because you're handling
guns there's a physical component
there's a physical component most one
day physical uh component it's called a
field day field day field day yeah good
you represent M Kelly thank you to
follow up on that who runs the program
the hunting
program the public affairs division has
a hunter education program with several
staff who work the hunter education
program so that is run through our
division represent Murray thank you
again um it seems like the funding from
that comes from the it's federal aid and
Wildlife restoration act would that is
that funds are those funds at risk uh
with this holding all federal funds so
would this facility necessarily or
possibly have to shut down if you don't
have that or you'd be able to keep it
open and is this also potential um
Revenue Source I'm always you know with
um representative I'm sorry I'm sorry
thank you um is this a possibility for
classrooms you and education for high
school students or something are there
classes that could come there and take
just a a wildlife class as part of their
curriculum which would potentially be a
small Revenue Stream So the last part of
your question about the wildlife
curriculum our public affairs unit and
their team is currently looking into
that and working with I mean they have
some already constructed curriculums
constructed for different programs and
well the uh the first part of your
question as far as yes this could be
impacted what does that mean for us I I
I'm not Doom day I I try to be positive
here and I try to look on ways that we
might be able to um you know get through
situations that we're dealing with the
the one interesting point about the
current federal funding pause is that
there are some clear things that have
been articulated and right now we do not
seem to fall under those so we may be
okay uh I'm counting on that I'm I'm
putting all my energy and positive
thought in that direction uh if it were
to come through where it does affect us
we will certainly make some contingency
planning and we'll see what that that
welcome you mentioned you did a ways and
means presentation recently it sounded
like you actually had a slide
presentation for that no not a slide
just a handout a handout okay but a hand
out what you must have produced
electronically um you printed that from
a document yeah yeah could you send the
docu the electronic document to to
Mickey sure I I did provide it to cret
Mickey we we do have it posted online as
a ways and means document but I will
send it to the committee so you have
that just okay send me a link that'd be
you representative
Dy forgive me for asking this question
but I'm always thinking about silos
silos you provide a service to your
constituents here or our consti consents
in the state of Main and other
areas do we think in the process of each
one of these silos should be self funded
from the activity that we're doing like
the hiking the fishing all of those
components all the expenses should be
offset by the revenue that you bring in
from th those particular activities do
we and and I sorry I worked in
manufacturing so I never worked in your
line of work um do you think in those
terms we do have have many areas of
programs that are funded exactly the way
in which you're speaking of such as
dedicated accounts like ohrv funds come
into ohrv which is a very large
component of our budget funds in that in
that account are strictly used to fund
that program the wildlife habitat
program funds within that account are
strictly used to fund that program we
have 16 dedic ated accounts within the
department that are strictly funded that
way however if you take us by division
and you take the Fisheries the Inland
Fisheries
division there's a great need there for
funding right now in our Hatchery
infrastructure we do not have enough
revenues coming in through all of our
programs to cover the needs that are in
the Fisheries division
Wildlife however uses a small amount of
unrestricted fishing game funds because
there is a large component of federal
funds and dedicated funds within that
Division if you were to look in your
budget books so the wildlife division
more than pays for the Wildlife division
so it's very hard when you have
divisions into put them in those silos
search and rescue pays for search and
rescue although not all of the
cost um so we do a mixture yeah it's
it's a mixture okay thank you and and
that's not uncommon for a fish and
wildlife agency using a mixture like
that is is the way you can get more done
because it's very often some some units
will bring in a lot more money and then
you can and there's a cross-pollination
anyway and I'll be honest with you I'm
trying to break down the siles within my
agency I want us all working together um
but there's cross-pollination you know
protecting habitat well that habitat is
good for ulet it's good for game birds
it's good you know it's also good for uh
bird watchers right that kind of thing
so so the 16 dedicated funds you
referred to you raise fees as necessary
so to maintain the self-funding status
how does that part of it work it depends
upon the statute that created that
dedicated fund such as wildlife habitat
and Fisheries habitat that that's the $1
on the Fisheries on the fish license
wildlife habitat is paid annually by
anybody who purchases any type of
hunting license that's $22.50 CS public
boat access program that's the $5 per
boat registration is um transferred to
us from the Department of Safety based
on the number of boats that are
registered the non-game program is
funded mainly by donations although
there is a very large fed when I talk
about dedicated accounts some of them
have Federal funds within those
dedicated accounts as well but there are
absolutely no fish and game funds within
those dedicated accounts fish uh
pheasant is a prime example the only
funds going into the Pheasant account is
from the sale of that Pheasant permit
and the only expense that comes out of
that Pheasant account is to purchase
those
birds okay so you mentioned that there
were 16 that it sounded like you said
were self-funding that correct okay so
those 16 in
particular how does it happen that they
all wind up being naturally self-funding
do you do you occasionally increase the
fees to make them such or somehow we
have we have increased the Pheasant fee
to make it um
self-funding just in the statute they
are
self-funded um and again there can be a
mixture of Revenue like the wildlife
habitat account there's a significant
amount of federal funds in there when
we're making say a million doll land
purchase 75% of that could come from
$750,000 when you say that in the
statute that makes it self funding can
you clarify what you mean by that the
language in the statute is all the
pretty much all the same for self-funded
uh accounts they are continually
appropriated non-aps right they do not
lapse as of June 30th any balance in
that fund goes forward and after years
of being Frugal you can have a nice
balance in that account and it es and
flows with expenditures and projects
right okay and so can you provide us
with a list of all the funds current
balances and growth over time okay
absolutely okay thank you did represent
of papichi thank you Mr chairman first I
need to um apologize for being remiss
and congratulating director simek for
her appointment I honestly we threw it
right Into The Gauntlet and I never took
the moment to really tell you how happy
we are that we see you here and that you
joined us I uh looked up your work in
Washington state and uh I think it is
impressive and I I I you know I'm
looking forward to you being a great
leader for the department and again my
complete apologies for being single
minded and Diving head long into
business instead of just uh you know
taking a moment to acknowledge and
celebrate no apologies needed but thank
you very much fish game is also very
thankful that director simic is here to
lead us I am looking forward to U you
know a lot of success for the Department
with you know the leadership team so I
just wanted to point out that one of the
discussions we had was along the lines
that chairman Earth was bringing up
about the fees that may need to be
updated and we spoke about the fact that
some you may have the statutory
authority to do so some you may not I
think one of the recommendations was
along the lines of uh you know maybe
legislation to give you a bit more
authority to raise the fees as needed
given that whether there is a bill or
not I'm sure we can find a way to um
help maybe in hb2 if
needed would you please include in your
presentation a list of fees that you
currently may not have the authority to
increase by yourselves that you feel
that Authority would be helpful and also
if you do that maybe a projection of
what you would feel the appropriate fee
would be and how would that impact the
budget I understand that every little
fee may just be a little amount compared
to the overall budget but we do need to
have a very systemic look at every
little thing and make sure that
everything is in Balance right
that I I don't want to get overly long
on this but but do you see what I'm
asking for here is that something that
could be provided when we meet again yes
you other questions
comments any
other I I would just like to add that
our dedicated account in the fishing
game Fund in itself is a dedicated
account they're mostly in pretty good
shape I mean some of them certainly
could benefit from a fee
increase
our issue is the unrestricted fishing
game fund that is where we need
help we do not have enough funding in
the unrestricted fishing game fund to
cover the
expenditures coming out of that fund and
the majority of those expenditures are
your support areas in the department
like the business office the director's
office
HR that we don't have federal funds to
draw down on we don't have dedicated
accounts also explain the difference
between the dedicated accounts that you
have and what you refer to as the
unrestricted fishing game fund so what
distinguishes the unrestricted fishing
game fund unrestricted funds are
different than restricted funds FS
restricted funds absolutely are
dedicated funds federal funds and
they're all earmarked for specific
projects and programs unrestricted
fishing game funds can be used for all
other department operations well I
understand the word unrestricted I guess
the really the question is so your
restricted ones you've explained to us
where the funding is coming from where's
the funding coming from in the UND
districted ones are there not fees
associated with that one as well or that
absolutely absolutely would be part of
the presentation that we did for house
ways and means we actually have 13
individual pots of money that that make
up the unrestricted fishing game fund
all licenses being the biggest part um
so all of these little interest earnings
on our savings indirect cost recoveries
on federal grants so essentially what
you're talking about is the big one
there is licenses in terms of things
that we can
control and you don't really want to
raise those because of the cost of of
the licenses in surrounding states so so
that's the fundamental problem with that
one every time you raise license fees
you drop volume yeah well that makes
sense you know the the volume
drops and since we're already very high
compared to our surrounding states it
just does not make sense at this time to
fees why is it that
or maybe we should be changing
things why is it that the the one
license that funds that one is strictly
the hunting license why couldn't some of
the other license the other fees
also pay play into the unrestricted
Fund in other words the one the one
license that you don't want to change is
the the the price hunting or fishing and
there's there's a long list of we have
over a hundred different license types
in the unrestricted fund
yes many all of your Marine licenses
what about raising the some of those
other ones then or is it the same
problem you honestly I need to I've been
looking at our rates for all of our
license types compared to other states
um there may be a few that we can you
know raise and and as representative
said you know few dollars here a few
dollars there it adds up um but overall
I think most of our pricing is either
above or right at the the average and we
would probably lose um numbers license
holders so I'm trying to go beyond that
yeah you it sounded like when you when
you rattled off what comes out of the
unrestricted fund it was more than just
supporting the fishermen or the hunters
or that sort of thing you talked about
overhead and so on and so forth right
and these other dedicated funds that you
have it sounds like that's not they're
not expected to support those overhead
expenses of the department why wouldn't
you consider raising some of those fees
as well and having them also contribute
to the overhead uh costs of the
department does that make sense what I'm
asking so those dedicated funds do yeah
support the overhead in the
department every year I process What's
called the internal administrative
charge on the majority of our dedicated
accounts those that you can take that
charge statutorily like the Pheasant
account cannot because it strictly says
in the statute it can only be used for
the purchase or propagation of
pheasants so I back charge those
accounts and those funds are deposited
into the unrestricted fishing game fund
so they do pay for a portion of the
Department all right let me pushing this
a little harder
so how many accounts are there like the
Pheasant account that perhaps we should
be increasing pheasant fees and or at
least letting them go towards the
overhead as well and words it sounds
like there's those accounts some of
those have uh balances positive balances
they do and maybe we should be using
more of that funding to help support the
One Fund that you apparently is the
biggest problem that that you refer to
again that's legislative changes there's
there's so that's what I want to get out
please tell me the legislative changes I
think what we need to do is we need to
look through them because there to be
honest with you it's a very convoluted
thing it's this one is legislative this
one is something else so we need to go
through them and we will bring you the
ones that are relevant for consideration
here yes and then um I I understand
where you're going and I think you're
spot on and so we will bring that
forward to you it's again back to your
question it it's mixed the way we fund
the agency is mixed and it's convoluted
just not just in within the way we do
things but because of laws and
regulations that we have in in set but
this is the place that can change the
laws that's what we do here so so please
bring bring that sort of information
forward so that we know um that's why we
have this thing called hb2 this this
Committee in particular uh can very
readily change the laws thank you very
much I you know I I'll just say thank
you for your grace I I know I'm coming
in a little naive to New Hampshire in
our process here so I appreciate your
patience with me oh yeah and this agency
I we're going to get them on the right
foot I'm G to learn I'm G to get you you
won't see this again I'll come in here
next time much more prepared no just we
also I also don't want to get ahead of
the governor's office to be honest with
you and so I I was just like well we'll
go there we'll see what their questions
are and right fair enough I I have no
problem with that I just wanted if
there's any more questions about what to
expect let me I I'm with you please let
us know because we want to do whatever
we can to help you now that doesn't mean
we're going to be able to do everything
but we're certainly willing to work with
you just one moment um representative Dy
representative hacken Phillips thank you
it really doesn't matter when I asked
the question um it might actually be for
Mickey um I'm just wondering you know
what is the Precedence for our you know
legislative body kind of like supporting
the unrestricted Revenue funds for
fishing game um have there been
circumstances in the past that um or
other parts of the department to to
support their operations you know what
is the kind of like backstory on um
their solvency I guess that's the
question so I can provide a history to
the committee of all the general fund
support that has been provided to
fishing game it's going back several
budgets now from when the fund was
pretty
uh uh close to you know a zero balance
it's built up I think we're planning on
closing 24 with about a $13 million
balance so it's much healthier than it
used to be yes um but I can provide that
to the committee and just so you can see
the history of the general fund support
and how it's
grown and that's great but I want to go
beyond that and understand all these
other funds and what can be done there
as well in terms of increasing revenues
um outside of the general fund revenues
yeah so so the the state does publish a
dedicated f fund report so all these
dedicated funds are provided with some
narrative and some history like a 5-year
history going back so we can provide
that to the committee too with statutory
references and everything so that it's
you look at a bigger picture than just
the unrestricted fishing game fund right
thank you and and just just to note most
all of those with the exception of maybe
a couple are part of house bill one so
you do see all of those accounts in
house bill one with an agency income or
restricted fund or whatever uh source of
fund rather than fishing game funds so
all of those will be part of the budget
package they were part of the agency
budget package too but they're just not
part of the unrestricted fishing game
fund where the department says they and
as you know I'm looking at a spreadsheet
which doesn't have those references so
that's the part of the problem if a
little broader inter relationship
between the spreadsheet and the actual
behind the scenes stuff um
representative D thank you just to
follow up on the revenue streams that
you have I would not sell myself short
on try taking a look at what your
um past experience has been in
increasing the licenses fees just go
through and do an analysis of it and see
if it really did go down if there
weren't any extenuating circumstances
because New Hampshire is loved and
people come here for a reason they don't
go to Maine for a reason they come here
for a reason so I think you might
surprise yourself that you could bump it
up a buck people not going to you know
say anything about it they're just going
thank you I representative Murray I
think this is also probably for Mickey
can we make a you know like to say the
Pheasant fund is going to have $100,000
more I know it won't be about $100,000
more than it would possibly have can we
make that statutory change in hb2 to say
excess can go or is that something that
really would have to go through fishing
game or are we um are we empowered to to
take that kind of a route that specific
a route
for all the dedicated funds that are set
up in statute that have Revenue going in
it that's State that's from State uh
mandated I guess or or in law certainly
you could you could you could do sweeps
of dedicated funds or anything like that
you would just want to be careful for
the federal funds that maybe go through
any of these accounts and those would be
subject to different rules but the stuff
that is established in State Statute you
can unestablished if you wanted or
change represent papichi thank you Mr
chairman
the agency has a long history of um
being self-funded and trying really hard
to uh you know match the revenues with
the um expenses and I know that times
are harder these days but I want to make
sure you understand that while we will
consider every possible solution to the
issues for myself I would very much like
to exhaust every possibility of
finding you helping you guys match the
revenues and expenses through user fees
and you know charging the people that
are using the services and the general
fund permanent general fund you know
funding would be a l resort to be used
you know break that window in case of
emergency type situation
so we we really need you to look at
every possible way to you know help this
committee get there if at all possible
right I just wanted to emphasize that
because it's only fair that you know you
know where at least I am coming from and
I don't think I'm by myself here right
so we are looking at every possibility
we look in every nook and corner and
cranny to see what we can do and I want
you to be aware of it and you know help
us by giving us for example those uh
agency you know those uh dedicated funds
sure we can look at the spread but
you guys know the story behind it you
have the color that we need to make
those decisions you know I cannot just
look at a balance and say well this
seems to be available all that needs to
be discussed with you and understood and
see whether that's a reasonable thing to
do when funding and so on so we will
need a lot of background data to you
know guide us through those type of
decisions so again you know just making
sure that you know what will want to
look at okay
cool representative Kelly thank you just
to see if I can make my question clear
so of the federal funds are there any
matching funds that are General funds or
state
funds that I want to be careful not to
cut any federal funds that might be
needing matching funds from the
state from the general
funds our general funds are specifically
focused within the law enforcement
division in accounting unit
7887 so we do not use any of the 1.3
million of General funds within that
funds so other so we would not be losing
any federal funds okay any place else
that you have federal funds that okay so
that's the only place okay that's the
uh further questions comments if I may I
put together a report on our dedicated
accounts it's not something I've sent to
the LBA I actually put it together for
internal purposes and for our
commission and it goes back about 10
years with the beginning balance
expenses revenues incumbrances ending
balance it also has a chart of that
fluctuation and also it starts with the
statute if that would be helpful for you
that would be awesome
okay have you seen that and and it's
electronic yes absolutely in color and
in color all right that would be awesome
thank you
cheap hey but it looks good and it takes
time any any other questions or
comments okay anything else from I just
want to say thank you again I appreciate
it I look forward to working with you
all and we'll certainly get you I've got
a long list here we'll certainly get
that information to you and make sure
that you have what you need and I
appreciate your support well thank you
for coming I hope it wasn't too
overwhelming I'm also new to this
position as well so I I don't in all
honesty I did not have a lot to do with
the last budget go around I kind of sat
in the back and director Mason and the
colonel were up here and um director
Simi wasn't sure what to expect and I
wasn't either because we've never been
asked to come before this committee
prior to the governor's budget being
released released and so I was a little
nervous I thought it'll just probably be
a question answer thing but we will put
together a nice product for you well it
was question and answer yes it was and
you guys did a great job for fantastic
hope it wasn't to overwhelming no not at
all thank you I appreciate your interest
and and your questions are valid they're
questions that I had myself just coming
back anything else to
discuss on the committee okay then any
else I needed to worry about Mickey then
the uh meeting's closed yeah me lunch
11:44
e
right that being just pass one we'll
open division two and we're starting
with the Department of Safety so if you
yourselves is that on Sir okay so good
afternoon uh my name is Robert Quinn I'm
the commissioner of the Department of
Safety and joining me is Miss Amy
administration may I proceed
yes sir well thank you so as stated I'm
Robert Quinn the commissioner of the
Department of Safety with me today I'm
joined by Amy Newry our director of
administration we're here to provide an
overview of the mission critical work
within the Department of Safety in our
agency budget requests for fiscal years
26 and 27 we continue to work closely
with Governor aart to sustain essential
Public Safety Services and meet growing
demands as she builds the governor's
budget for consideration by the house
the mission of the Department of Safety
is to consistently enhance safety
security and the quality of life in New
Hampshire through professional
collaborative and Innovative Services
May interrupt you just for a moment are
you following along with your slides or
you you doing an introduction this is
the introduction and I'm going to turn
it over for the slides okay I was say
just like if you're switching slides let
us
know cuz you're going in a Break N next
speed
[Laughter]
good our department consists of seven
divisions each with its own Public
Safety mandate and funding sources
demand for Public Safety Services
continues to grow across all areas as do
the demands on our Workforce in
developing this budget we followed our
strategic plan ensuring that our primary
goals remained Central While
acknowledging the challenges and
constraints that lie ahead we set
expectations at every level mindful that
each division has specific evolving
needs identified through key performance
metrics this message outlines the
challenges faced by the department due
to high vacancy rates budget constraints
and the need for modernization despite
these difficulties the team has
successfully maintained Public Safety
Services with limited resources however
as operational cost rise driven by
increasing salaries equipment
replacement expenses and a greater
dependence on it infrastructure some
critical positions remain unfunded this
is affecting Staffing levels and
delaying technology upgrades including
online services and systems Replacements
throughout this presentation we will
provide an overview of each division's
Mission Staffing levels funding
structure and Key Programs director Amy
Newbery will now highlight the essential
Public Safety mission of our seven
divisions we welcome any questions you
may have during the presentation and
look for forward to your engagement
thank
you that's good do you don't mind us
interrupting during the presentation no
whatever works for you sir okay all
right thank you commissioner and good
afternoon everyone so let's begin
today's presentation with an overview of
the Department of bring the microphone
closer to you so that it gets picked up
because otherwise the folks at home
can't hear us can't hear
you let's begin today's presentation
with an overview of the Department of
Safety and its structure which is
outlined on page
three as highlighted by the commissioner
the department of safety consists of
seven divisions each with a distinct fun
funding source this structure naturally
lends itself to a division byd division
presentation approach which is what I'll
follow today on page four you'll find a
summary of the overall departmental
agency budget request for fiscal year
2026 the department of safety is
requesting 265 million increasing to 2
73 million for fiscal year
2027 These funds are vital to supporting
Public Safety Services Statewide the
request will sustain a Workforce of
1,151 classified full-time positions and
14 unclassified roles as a Personnel
driven agency the majority of our budget
is allocated to salaries and benefits
the remaining 40% supports operating
expenses including grants distributed to
local agencies and other state
entities Pages 5 through S focus on the
office of the Comm mayup
you so you don't have to answer the
question now but at some point when need
talk talk about revenues could you tell
us what other revenues represents I
will Pages 5 through 7 focus on the
office of the commissioner which serves
as the backbone of the department this
office will not only provide not only
provides oversight for all seven
divisions but also directly manages
three critical areas the office of
Highway Safety the legal unit and the
Bureau of hearings the office of Highway
Safety develops and implements Statewide
traffic safety programs to reduce
crashes fatalities injuries and property
damage it also administers the highway
safety Federal grant program which
awarded 2.5 million in Grants to 136
local police departments in fiscal year
24 to fund overtime Patrols and enhance
enforcement
efforts the legal unit provides Legal
Services across the department including
administrative rule making labor issues
and compliance with federal and state
regulations the the unit also manages
right to no request ensuring
accountability and transparency the
Bureau of hearings conducts conducts
approximately 14,000 Administrative
Hearings annually and oversees appeals
litigation and the New Hampshire Motor
Vehicle Industry
Board in summary the office of the
commissioner ensures strategic
leadership and operational efficiencies
across the department page eight the
division of administration is introduced
this division provides internal support
across all divisions and includes six
bureaus financial management Human
Resources asset and Resource Management
Road tool grants management and facility
management the division's budget EST is
13 million for fiscal year 26 and 14
million for fiscal year 27 with 66%
allocated to salary and benefits for 84
classified and three unclassified
employees in fiscal year 23 the road
tool Bureau collected 183 million for
the highway fund other Key activities
within the division include processing
2.9 Million mail items and distributing
555,000 l pletes and 2 million Fleet
decals to municipalities and DMV
substations excuse me the division of
administration is primarily funded
through Highway represent
papichi very just a very brief question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here and testifying and taking
questions well testifying presenting my
bad Force The Habit um I was looking at
your 76 lcy audits could you just remind
us you know the nature of those audits
who are the licenses and what do you
generally what generally happens in an
audit and if that's covered later it can
wait just fine but if it's not covered
just a tiny bit of color on
okay um the division of administration
is primarily funded through the highway
and general funds however the
significant portion of operations is
supported by the application of indirect
cost recovery of dedicated funds that
the department oversees indirect cost
recovery is tied to a range the Min
sorry will you be talking about your
dedicated funds as well at some point
yes yes okay
beautiful she was prepared that you
would have a question on that
understanding how uniquely we are funded
and where the revenue is coming in right
now she she's doing great just it's
that's a she's moving right along you
both you both seem to be right on the
ball indirect cost recovery is tied to
the tied to the range of administrative
Services the division provides including
Human Resource Management grants
Administration and invoice processing
these essential support functions enable
the efficient operation of the
Department's various divisions ensuring
that critical programs and services are
de delivered
effectively pay age 12 we transition to
the Department of Motor Vehicles the
DMV's mission is to enhance Public
Safety on New Hampshire's roads by
ensuring all drivers vehicles and
service providers are properly
credentialed the division consists of
six bureaus driver licensing financial
responsibility which handles driver
history records operations registration
title and an Administration section on
page 13 DMV presents its budget request
seeking 34. 3 million for fiscal year 26
and 35.2 million for fiscal year 27 of
this budget 56% support salary and
benefits for 210 full-time classified
and two unclassified positions in fiscal
year 24 the DNB issued 372 926 motor
vehicle titles conducted 71,0 836 863
skills and road tests and produced 373
585 driver licenses and ID
cards DMV is primarily funded through
Costa collections which constitutes most
of its Financial Resources additional
funding comes from few smaller dedicated
sources such as the plate fund
motorcycle ride or training fund and
driver education
fund though these represent relatively
minor contributions the cost of
collection accounts for approximately 33
million of the dnb's total funding
page 14 outlines the diverse services
offered under the DMV which includes
licensing real ID issuance accident
reporting driver education and programs
for impaired drivers it also highlights
vehicle related services such as
registration titles inspections
emissions and specialized plates in
insuring ensuring safety compliance and
convenience for drivers and vehicle
owners Pages 15 through 17 focus on the
division of State Police which ensures
Public Safety and highways on highways
and at critical locations the state
123.3mi
and one unclassified
position the new Hampshire State Police
is funded through a combination of state
and federal resources at the state level
most of the funding comes from the
general fund however Highway funds and
Turnpike dollars also support this ad
this division Additionally the division
benefits from federal grants such as
those provided by the community oriented
policing services or cops program which
help fund initiatives like hiring
training and school security measures
the state police also received support
through the Department's grants
management Bureau which administers
additional Grant programs and Aid law
enforcement agencies across the state in
fiscal year 14
state so this might be a good place to
speak to the what appears to be a fairly
large increase in general funds in this
department 46.6 in fy2 24 adjusted and
then 54 if I'm not mistaken in fy20 six
right six on page four page 16 I was
looking at the bottom the darkest blue I
think that's General funds or is that
federal
funds it's General funds so looking at
FY 24 it's 46.6
million actual to adjusted yes right and
then I skip over to 27 54
million 26 is 26 what I meant to say I'm
sorry yes director can explain the jump
in the general funds that's what I was
curious about yeah thank
you are you you're looking at the actual
to adjusted correct yes the 24 actual
budgeted so the 26 so the actual 24 to
26 budgeted the differ has to do with
salary and
the I get there's a 10% salary increase
is that a big part of it so it's the
salary and benefits but also um a
reclassification of for state police as
well on top of that can can you explain
that that
was and the last FIS so that would have
been in 24 happened in 25 did we start 2
25 so they had an internal reallocation
then the 12% 10 and two so that equates
for the increase in the what was the
internal reallocation from Trooper all
the way up to Executive major they went
up a labor grade so there was a
reallocation internally oh like step
sort of correct step increases that
correct okay so that's that's basically
that whole P that all of that is pretty
much step increases plus the Sal
benefits the increases yes sir okay
welcome thanks um in fiscal year 24
State Police conducted
9193 motor vehicle stops arrested
1,233 impaired drivers and completed
6,299 n criminal investigations
addressing vacancies remains a top
priority budget adjustments include 2.7
million increase for contracts of body
cameras in 2.1 million in overtime cost
due to Staffing
gaps page 18 introduces the division of
Homeland Security and emergency
management responsible for coordinating
New Hampshire's response to major
natural and human-made disasters page 19
details hm's budget request of 26.5
million for fiscal year 26 and 26 8
million for fiscal year 27 with 28%
allocated to 42 classified and two
unclassified positions and 20 and 72%
towards operating funds mostly federal
grants through femma Homeland Security
program in fiscal year 22 hscm activated
the state's Emergency Operations Center
12 times facilitating 264 exercises and
approved 44 local Hazard mitigation
plans HSM secures funding through a
variety of federal and state sources to
support its comprehensive emergency
preparedness and response initiatives a
significant portion of hm's funding is
derived from Federal grant programs
administered by the Federal Emergency
Management agency or FEMA at the state
level HSM receives allocations from the
general fund to further bolster bolster
its Emergency Management capabilities
this combination of federal grants and
state funding enables HSM to effectively
coordinate preparedness response
recovery and mitigation efforts across
the state additionally HSM receives
response sorry to keep interrupt you so
the grants are these the kind of thing
the federal grants are these the kind of
thing that you you you expect every year
like they're just
broad-based grants to all the states or
are they do you apply for them and yeah
and some some of them are pass through
we're like the fiduciary for them grants
that go out to the public but yes a lot
of them we can we can plan for and uh
have been in um for the past several
bium okay and do you have details of
those yeah everything I'm not right now
but no we we have it all okay I am okay
can you provide details I should have
asked yeah and representative hen
phelips thank you Mr chair and thank you
um for answering my questions this is
really easy one I think on 19 I'm just
having a hard time deciphering between
the two dark blue bar chart colors so if
you could just clarify for me if the
larger portion of each bar graph is
either General funding or federal
funding so you can tell what the other
can then I think I think as director Nu
said that the significant portion is um
I apologize for that the dark blue you
have your hand up okay represent Papi
and just as a personal thing I do happen
to be color blind so for me colors are a
bit more of a challenge I can see the
shad and at the end I'm a numbers guy
but if we could contrast the colors a
bit more that would make the job easier
for I think not just me but definitely
for me so no stress that's good advice
additionally HSM receives funding
through emergency response programming
within the emergency planning zone as
authorized under RSA
107-b Section 3 to support preparedness
efforts Regulatory Compliance and
emergency response capabilities for SE
Brook station page 20 highlights the
divisions comprehens whoa whoa slow down
I don't think the rsa's actually
mentioned here could you just repeat the
3 and what did that relate to seab Brook
you you're a speed talker thank you
well page 20 highlights the division's
comp comprehensive approach to Emergency
Management emphasizing prevention
response recovery and mitigation it
showcases efforts like Comm community
outreach school safety programs and
Hazard mitigation planning supported by
training Statewide emergency
preparedness and Grant Management to
ensure Readiness and resilience across
state levels All State levels page 21
represents the division of emergency
services and communication which
operates New Hampshire's enhan 911
systems and maintains State Radio
Network on page 22 the division's budget
request is outlined at 20.1 million for
fiscal year 26 and 20.6 million for
fiscal year 27 with 74% of these funds
dedicated to salary and benefits for 130
classified and one unclassified employee
New Hampshire and question thank you
what funds the 911
fund the
um the charge and I'm that shows up on
our phone bills or what yep give me one
minute
okay really it's going to take you a
there so new hampers enhanced 911 system
is primarily funded through a dedicated
sear charge applied to various
communication systems the collected sear
charges are remitted to the state's
enhanced 911 system systems fund which
is utiliz I exclusive exclusively for
the development and operation of the
enhanced 911 services and the Statewide
emergency notification
system on page so these appear on our
phone bills yes anywhere else you sort
of sound like you rattle off more than
just no that's it that's okay so we
could actually see that on our own
individual bills it's one separate item
says 911 whatever okay great thank
you yes ma'am uh
representative Mary H you thank you um
can you just uh iterate that I guess
what do other uh Communications
organizations they don't contribute to
the 911 except through their phone bill
I mean is there any other charges that
come through communication services in
the state no I mean this like like
director Nuri said this search charge is
directly related to funding the
operations of the division of emergency
services and Communications the 911 we
have two PS
um one in conquered one in lonia and um
and then we have the network the overall
Network that rides on it so so that
individual communities would not be
funded through this so there would have
to be their own funding source at that
local Municipal level okay so I'm sorry
go ahead no you same question yeah go
ahead so when you say the indiv the
individual communities fund
themselves well I think I think the
question was how would radio um systems
be handled at the local level that would
be separate not exactly um I don't know
the names of companies but major
communication companies that function in
the state don't contribute to a 911 fund
like what's who does my
telephone Verizon does Verizon
contribute anything to this fund
themselves other than through you know a
phone bill or any other Communication
System it seems to me I what I'm trying
to get at it seems to me that there are
other entities that have an interest in
the 911 system that maybe should be
contributing to that as well we can
provide an exact list to you as to who
was on that and who isn't just so we're
we're certain we'll deal with you know
that that'd be great yeah if you could
get that to Mr Lander again that'd be
perfect thank you you did that I'm good
thank
you y um page 23 highlights the critical
support and operational functions
provided by the division including
seamless Communications for First
respons Responders fault tolerant
Network networking for 911 and
operational systems and the efficient
management of 247 emergency call centers
it also showcases the high standards of
quality assurance and administrative
oversight that ensures smooth operations
effective resource management and public
engagement for fiscal year 24 the
responded to 531 urgent law enforcement
requests achieved a
99.66% quality assurance rate completed
123 transfers to the 988 hotline and
managed 1
1,440 record requests for law
enforcement agencies this is probably a
naive question but what is the 988
hotline it's for Behavior heal okay
right behavioral health behavioral
was there another question on emergency
communications
okay page 24 moves to the division of
fire standards and training and EMS
which is dedicated to training
certifying and supporting emergency
responders in New Hampshire page 25
details the division's 11.2
million budget request a question here
of course this this is probably going to
be a little off the
charts
um so we have a requirement as I
understand it in in the fire standard
side of things there two levels of fire
certification fire one fire two yeah and
the fire two is the
more uh serious one right the harder one
the next one they go in that order one
and then two yes okay so the Fire 2 the
one we got to hike up the six steps six
flights and all the stuff on your back
and everything I would defer to director
cutting because he's the I wasn't a
firefighter but okay will he be coming
in here if if you want if you want more
detail on the curriculum on fire one as
opposed to fire two we can provide that
awesome I wouldn't I couldn't speak to I
have questions about it I I yes the
detail is great but I also would like to
talk to somebody who can answer
questions about that well we will
provide that that that's easy okay thank
page 25 details the division's $ 11.2
million budget request for fiscal year
26 and 11.5 million for fiscal year 27
with 72% of the funds supporting 40
classified and one unclassified employee
for fiscal year 24 the division enrolled
35,6 121 students issued
1,680 certification licensed 6,76 EMS
providers and licensed 5 to ambulances
page 26 are Key Programs and servic down
what funds the fire fund it is the fire
fund which I will get
to which I will get to because the fire
fund supports both fire standards and
the fire Marshall's office so when I
talk about the fire fund and um kind of
the also the challenges with the fire
fund um I'm going to kind of talk about
both fire academy and and the fire
Marshall's office together so I'm going
to start with um fems get to fmo and
then I'm going to talk about the fire
fund and also the challenges okay
everybody else good all right carry
on so
um they on page 26 are Key Programs and
services including specialized
firefighter and Emergency Medical
Services training curriculum development
and professional certification with
state of-the-art facilities and
Equipment the division ensures
highquality education testing and
compliance for emergency Personnel while
also managing licensing Statewide trauma
systems and data analysis to support
Public Safety initiatives on page 27
focuses on the division of fire safety
which aims to prevent deaths and
property loss through fire safety
education enforcement and
investigation page 27 details the
division budget request of 5.8 million
for fiscal year 26 and 5.8 million for
fiscal year 27 with 80% dedicated to
salaries and benefits for 26 classified
and one unclassified employee in fiscal
year 24 the division investigated 87
fire in incidents conducted 1,89 safety
inspections and completed 1,112 building
plan reviews page 29 highlights the Key
Programs and services provided by the
division showcasing its comprehensive
approach to Public Safety which includes
building safety inspections fire
investigations community outreach and
emergency response coordination ensuring
the safety of well-being for residents
across the
state fems and fmo are supported by
Revenue primarily generated from fees
associated with the provision of copies
of Motor Vehicle records and
certificates these records are
requested so now you're speaking to what
funds the fire fund yes sir and it's
only what you just said the say that
again yep so it is primarily generated
it's primarily generated revenue is
primarily generated from fees associated
with the provision of copies of Motor
Vehicle records and
certificates records are requested by
insurance companies and other authorized
recck agents in accordance with
RSA
14 the fees collected so so so yes so
slow down there so um these are so when
there's a fire I assume that's when
insurance companies are trying to get
records no no it actually um so it's
when um and it's when companies are
requesting
from
the dnv a record on um they they're
trying to sell somebody um an insurance
policy and they're looking for their
motor vehicle history it could be
something like
that okay so these are records requests
of DMV and only DMV or other DMV DMV
only
DMV so you have or so corporate
interests have the ability to make these
requests with DMV through statute yeah
through statute yeah yeah yeah no I just
understand so here's a question for you
related to DMV and Records
requests the judicial branch do they
records what type of Records like is it
through a court case or uh say birth
dates
in particular I mean give I'm I'm not
quite sure I'm falling
so so if there's a criminal case yep
there'd be provided Discovery but when
you say the judicial branch when you
speak to the court I'm not quite sure
okay so um a a judge has issued a bench
warrant for somebody's arrest and one of
the things that's required for that
bench warrant is for the sheriff to then
actually go out and and and serve the
the warrant is a birth date does the and
all those go through yeah all goes
through the criminal justice system so
birth dates would be on warrants which
are all approved and so it should be a
no-brainer for the judicial department
or the sheriff's department to get that
information and that's all because it's
coming through law enforcement so that's
all through law enforcement so if
somebody is somebody is to get an arrest
warrant or bench warrant there would
have to been an investigation or
violation of law which would ultimately
have worked up to that well this is a
little bit the inverse um somebody goes
to small claims court and files a claim
um against a
contractor and the contractors be
obliged to come before the court doesn't
come before the court and then has he's
obliged to come before the court again
doesn't come before the court and then
the judge issues a bench warrant which
goes to apparently a Sheriff from what I
understand to process it and the sheriff
comes back and says to the claimant
you need to get the birth date of the
contractor okay I would I I wouldn't
feel comfortable answering that specific
question but what I think I would do is
we will provide the driver privacy
section of the law through Mickey to
understand to make sure that what a
judge can do and what the public can do
are different and what law enforcement
can do so maybe if if you could give me
in detail the exact question like the
exact
example and then we will look at that
representative chair I as an attorney
who has dealt with some of these bench
works in the past for folks who have
defaulted and not shown for cause um
hearings if you don't have the birth
date to submit to law enforcement I
don't I kind of think your that's where
your case ends more or
less my understanding so that's what
that's the question I want answered is
why is it that a judge can issue a bench
warrant and the state
whatever
entity cannot process that without going
back to the
claimant and my question is I don't know
how a judge could would issue a bench
warrant if they didn't have a date of
birth right but I I that's we will we
will I'm telling you what's happened and
I spoke to the the head of the district
court and she said that's exactly what
happened that's exactly what's happening
she's looking into why the sheriff can't
get the birth date so that's why I'm
asking you the question because you guys
are the guys that provide the
information and I will work with the
courts and we will get you an answer
perfect thank
you yes ma'am I'm sorry repres represent
Murray along the same lines um you know
you talked about the example of someone
applying for an insurance policy and
they're looking to see you know how many
crashes you've had I'm assuming first of
all that um if I'm the one applying for
the policy I've given them permission to
go look at my thing which it begs the
question it says on my ride alance which
I try to do at least one a year with the
people I and I know the answer to this
and I really respect that it's a hard
not but I always like to ask would you
look me up and they can't they're very
clear that no we absolutely cannot look
up your says it's my file I'm giving you
permission to do that and they're like
nope you haven't done anything wrong
we're not going to look up your file and
it just seems strange to me that I can't
request my own information just I'm
curious I really I I know there's
nothing there I haven't had a ticket
since I was probably 32 but you can
request your own you know driving along
in the car you know and when I'm in the
ride along I was he's you know you stop
he stop someone look up and said would
you look me up he's like no can't do
that he's smart telling you that because
he would have been violating the law
right exactly but my guess my point is
that um I can give permission to a
corporate entity which you know fine if
I want the insurance that they can look
it up but it's always amused me that it
is such a hard no when I ask the police
officer sitting next to me would you
mind looking up my record and they're
like they will not cross that line and I
respect them for doing that but we will
forward the driver privacy statute
because it it is um is just curious to
me because it's my data but thank you
well just to follow up on that you said
that we can request our record you can
request your own data how you can go
through the DMV if you want a copy of
your Motor Vehicle Record you can
request if you want your own criminal
record if you have your own name and
date of birth you submit it you pay $25
you get your own record okay thank you
they won't do it in the patrol
car and that's the process to get your
that's fine no you answer my question
are you done are you continuing no I
sorry thank
you so getting back to the fire fund um
we the um to sustain operations and meet
statutory obligations a $4 million
transfer to the fire fund is requested
to maintain existing levels of service
to Residents and local
agencies this appropriation shall be
non-lps and pursuant to RSA
2-p section
12-d in conclusion the department of
safety's fiscal year 26 and 27 budget
requests reflect our commitment to
maintaining effective Public Safety
Services addressing rising cost and
ensuring strategic resource
allocation we look forward to
collaborating with the governor and
legislature to sustain our mission and
priorities so that last part could you
just repeat that very slowly you talking
about the fire fund is that accurate yes
okay yes so we have requested a $4
million transfer into the fire
service I got that part and you
mentioned a an RSA 21 -
12-d okay and and what is that what does
that section relate to the um it will
allow for the transfer into a dedicated
non-aps yes Miss represented Kelly um
where is that transfer coming from I'm
sorry if you said it I don't General
us um continue or where are you in the
process I haven't
done yeah so I can ask another question
yes sir no we're done and I hope that
was I hope but um you don't know
anything about fires huh because you got
there okay one of my questions is and
you don't need to answer this right now
but hope provide the information um is a
list of your dedicated funds and the
sources of revenues for them and the
rsas that uh control
them we will provide that to Mickey yeah
perfect thank you other people yes
represent D Roy I know that the safety
department has had a very difficult time
Oh I thought you would tell me to some
um hiring people you slated a bunch of
positions over the year right and you
w't aable to fill those positions those
funds are those non-aps funds and they
move over into the next budget or do you
just kind of that goes in there and then
we raise the budget again okay I'll let
Amy that's what you're talking about is
mainly the class 10 funds which we have
from the vacancies from the vacancies
thank you there vacancies is those funds
do sweep in the bium they sweep okay
thank you to clarify that that means it
will lapse back to either the general
fund or the highway Fund in the case of
Highway funded positions back to those
undesignated Surplus balances they don't
stay with the Department they're not
rolling
forward yes sir representative
Bean thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question this is not related
to the budget um it's to do with the uh
background
checks I've got a problem with a
department in bellnap county that uh
they they're telling me that it takes
eight weeks to get a background check I
want to know how long it takes from the
time you receive the background check to
the time you get it back to the
department So currently the numbers and
I checked today before I came over we
are we are zero but it's important
because we we fed a lot of phone calls
on this but today we are zero to five
days turnaround on your record check
with zero backlog there is no backlog
and that's been consistent for 18 months
now I think sir I think and and and it's
easy to have some confusion because you
use the term background so we at the
department of safety do not do a
background check we provide a record so
we either provide the state record the
state criminal history or we provide the
FBI fingerprint-based record if there is
a record convictions so when an employer
or an agency requests that the state
record can be done on our portal so it
you can put in the submission you can
pay and you can get that back
electronically and that's you can get
that within a day fairly
quickly follow up just just go on so are
there any other records that are needed
this is for the nursing home so I what I
would say is this what I would Point
them to is first of all have them call
the criminal records Bureau today but
they may have been provided their record
and then I can't speak to any further
checks that need to be done on the
employer side but when they need the
record from us we can turn that around
very quickly and we have but again it's
complicated So when you say background
maybe they have a record and they still
need to do more work or there's more
checks or you know there's unique um
layers add additional layers before the
person's hired what we've done in the
past what we've experienced is sometimes
agencies go to a third party vendor to
get the background check and and and
sometimes and they have gone to like
various courts to see if there are
records which takes time but the state
criminal record if there are convictions
is done is instantly and our um
Christine Shay who runs the criminal
records Bureau has done a very good job
staying on top of this being responsive
but those numbers are accurate so if you
have a constituent that's waiting what I
would do is we will speak to them but I
would Point them back to the employer
and say do you have my record and if you
have my record what's what's holding
this up my hiring well this is the
department the the nursing department in
belau County they told us the part of
the reason that they can't get lnas is
because it takes eight weeks to do a
background check on a potential employee
well it may take 8 weeks for someone to
do a background check but you're getting
that state record within I would say
close to a day and the FBI record once
we get the prints that's coming back in
five days so zero to five days and you
can get in today to get an appointment
so if you need to get in to get an
appointment on one of our live scan
machines the apist machines you can get
in so I checked today before testifying
0 to 5 days turnaround no backlog and
it's been like that for 18 months thank
you very much I think there's some
confusion Sir with it and and we will we
will work with them so have them call us
and we can we can get that done by the
end of the day there may or may not be
any confusion okay but that's that's
accurate coming from them and they do a
good job and and just to highlight too
I'm also involved in a in a a task force
that's worked on this multi-agency task
force through statute but in the group
we have the Commissioner of Health and
Human Services uh Department of
Education Department of Revenue Office
of professional lure Lottery Commission
we're dealing with some external
stakeholders uh School administrators uh
the association of counties the banking
department and one
more the municipal Association to look
we've met once already is there anything
we can do internally is there anything
that can be done to speed this process
up but I think we are we are as tight as
we can be if you come on one of our
portals one of our portals that connects
to the state system so it sounds like
he's heard this problem
before but they're blaming it on you
obviously but honestly sir a customer
service have them call them we'll talk
to them we'll we'll we'll figure it out
and we'll help yeah perfect thank you
very much representative hacken Phillips
yeah I just thank you Mr chair I just
wonder if it's possibly like a some sort
of DHHS CMS
type Health Care protocol that's not
part of that equation but may also be
included in this check for folks who are
trying to work in the nursing home so um
guess represent
D in terms of Revenue um for the police
department or for the Troopers we
haven't had a lot so we haven't seen a
lot on the highways a lot of speeding is
happening and you know that so my my
assumption is that we're not getting the
revenue that we need because people
aren't being stopped or being fined for
going 80 or 90 miles an hour down the
turnpike and Spalding being one of them
I would love to
see a
chart for the last say three or four
years on what revenue is being generated
by the Troopers for uh people who are
you know violating the
law sure no we can provide that it would
be interesting to see this is what
happens because people are talking about
this now people are very concerned about
the fact that there's nobody on the
turnpike stopping people from going fast
but that revenue is a deterrent right I
mean nobody wants to get a $500 fine but
if we're not doing if we're not
performing that service we're not
getting the revenue to you know actually
support other departments here that we
need um so there's kind of it's like a
two so no thank you for bringing that up
and and and director nuber can get the
stats on you know the history but I I
will say this and I I think it's
important well we acknowledge that there
are vacancies within the division of
State Police I want to be clear that we
have seen tremendous interest the
recruitment unit is doing a great job we
are seeing good candidates the colonel
of the State Police the recruitment of
training the leadership is working well
consist consistently through this um
I would say um you know lull and hiring
but we are on the the uptick um it looks
very good promising when it comes to
activity they recognize as well as
anyone the excessive speeds we've seen
some terrible crashes but I can tell you
that their activity is is extremely high
they are working very hard out there so
I've been working closely and I'm very
proud of what they're doing so it may
seem like we're you're not seeing as
many but they have a strategy so they're
out there with the special enforcement
unit they're working with the aircraft
so they're seeing what you're seeing and
um and I believe they're doing a very
good job and as we continue to add to
the ranks of the State Police which we
will we will you will continue to see
more and will drive this number down but
there's there's been no quitting them
and they're working harder today than
they ever
work so repres
Papi thank you and uh seriously thank
you for providing some background on
that I just wanted to add that as far as
I'm
concerned your enforcement is about
safety I don't necessarily look at the
Troopers as a source of Revenue the
revenue they get is incidental I'm
generally very concerned about pushing
you guys for more Revenue because it
tends to lead to more aggressive
ticketing that may not be in the best
interest of Public Safety if done
incorrectly for the sake of Revenue so I
just wanted to say that I recognize you
have a very complex job and I think you
guys are doing a great job of balancing
all these different priorities and I
would urge you to have a very strong
focus on the public safety which based
on what you are saying you guys are
already doing and I appreciate it and I
would like to continue doing that I
appreciate that and their mission is
safety and they're not focused on the
revenue representative Murray uh thank
you Mr chair I have three little
questions which you can probably weave
into one narrative um you know on page
four you can see the drop in federal
funds um which you put to use can you
speak to what those funds were used for
and what the loss of that Federal
funding will mean going forward um and
in the same instance um what the uh
freeze or the pause on you know the
Trump's grant funding pause how that
will affect you going forward because
you have a lot of impact with federal
funds and the third thing is how would
you have addressed the 4% um decrease in
revenues that was requested by the
governor's so does that make sense sort
of what did you use that you know the
the federal money for back in 2024
what's going to be missing because that
goes away um the pause in grant funding
which we we have no idea where that's
going to go and the 4% so I'm going to
let Amy take this but I think just so
it's the reduction that's shown it's the
freeze and then the additional reduction
what's the overall impact so the overall
impact on federal
funds we have this bro
so um so to start the um the reduction
the significant reduction is the
co9 um so the um the next question you
had was know within that what can you
give a few examples of what you use that
covid money for and what it means going
forward not getting it um I assume some
of this if you can speak to
infrastructure um or whatever programs
you use that for and what it means when
it's gone I mean we can provide that I
mean that's a comprehensive list but
that all went through you know Homeland
Security and Emergency Management but if
you want to look at you know what was
requested what was reimbursed at the
local level the state level yeah I think
that that would be best answered by the
director of Homeland Security to kind of
give an overview of all of the
initiatives under covid-19 and the
funding that went out to the locals I
think he would be best to answer that I
can certainly get that for you but
that's the significant jump there um
reduction mhm we we'll get it that's not
sure
certainly and then you asked about the
freeze at this point we have reached out
to all of our federal partners and are
just at this point waiting for um
forward and um can you did if you've had
a chance to already um address the
request for a 4% decrease in the budget
where how has that affected you or have
you have you looked at that yet or do we
wait for Valentine's
Day We are continuing to work with the
governor and her team to address that
thank
you just related to that I got you but
on the same point um so were you able to
affect that in your agency budget
request the 4% reduction we are we have
and will continue to work with Governor
a and her team and I believe that they
understand the unique mission of the
department and how it impacts both
Public Safety and customer service no I
I totally get that but you actually have
already published a your agency request
I'm just curious where did you get to at
that at that point in the process
Targets in the agency phase that's okay
um I just had a clarification on the
arpa if I may thank you Mr chairman so
on the arpa funds I think that speaking
for myself when I want to use the look
of the arpa funds I want to make sure
that they were used as they were
intended as onetime use and there is
nothing that leads to to us having to
now add permanent funding to something
that we started with ARA I cannot speak
for my colleagues but for me that would
be my perspective when I look at those
numbers I want to ensure that they were
used for one-time projects as they were
meant to
be just clarifying I feel confident that
our division understands what those
funds were and they're one-time funds
good we good so far
oh yeah well no no go ahead I'm right
these are more fun or maybe
not can you uh speak to the impact of
cost of rescues on you because this has
been a um a big year you you're involved
with rescues in the White Mountains
that's mainly fishing game that's okay I
checked with them I thought you had some
impact with that as well uh the other
thing where uh I know Rockingham County
you six hour guns the sheriff's
department did uh they had a real
problem because they jammed and 6our did
not respond positively to that um do you
know where any of that stands in terms
of your ability to get your Firearms I
don't know who who makes a decision
about who buys what guns from where but
I know that Rockingham County is now
going out of state because six hour was
not responsive do you have any
information I can't speak I can't speak
to siga but the division of State Police
which is overseen by the colonel colonel
Mark Hall he has a team and if we are
going to look at new Firearms as a
process they have a comprehensive team
team of experts firearms experts and
instructors that will test and then they
will look and they will make evaluations
and it will go up through the chain and
um so they'll put a lot of work into it
but that's and just one last thing can
you address the big um you know concerns
I guess you know rightful concerns will
big to do around um Interstate 95 and
the increase the Interstate 95 and the
inre in accidents there and I know this
dovet tales with Transportation no thank
you for the question and I think
I mean um I mean it was terrible the
rash of crashes we had there and the
median crossover ones in a short period
of time and um quite honestly when
people ask why you have to wait till the
reports are in before you make any um
comments like what caused that you know
it could have been speed it could have
been it could have been a medical issue
so but irregardless what we have done is
we've got a process and a team in place
and the colonel immediately worked with
the troop commander and a special
enforcement unit so we put really a
concentration there on 95 in that
Northern Area and um but it's not really
that it's all highways it's all roads so
they're looking across but um you know
and and you know the median um the
cables that's really do but we work
closely with DOT the office of Highway
Safety so it's either an Enforcement
issue it's an education issue or maybe
it's an engineering issue it's Road
design so you have to work together but
to really get the root cause of these
you have to wait till the unfortunately
if it's a fatal till the fatal accident
report is done then we find out so I'm
very sensitive to comment on an
individual crash when the reports aren't
done but we're working hard so stepped
up enforcement more messaging more
education and um and hopefully we can
see a reduction not only there but on
all of our
highways you yes thank you R Papi thank
you Mr here just to come back a little
bit to the search and rescue I know it's
a minor concern of yours because it is
handled mostly by fishion game but in
speaking with them this fall they were
telling me that sometimes they have to
pull resources from other agencies some
somebody might have a chopper somebody
may have sure whenever you cooperate
with them you know was there any time
when you know it was imbalanced when you
know you may have felt that uh they
should compensate you for some of the
resources or is it stuff that inter
agencies you know gets exchange all the
time cooperation and we are all good on
that one it's seamless and fishing game
are really the experts in that and going
out and doing a rescue they're doing and
if they need our CT team if they need
additional help we help and um but
there's never been an issue where we've
had to bill so we you know we use
additional resources but um you know I
appreciate it I just wanted to
understand if you guys had any concerns
didn't really expect anybody it's better
to ask than to assume so no I have the
utmost respect for them what they do in
those weather conditions they great uh
you okay back to my way early question
about other in all these
cases you don't need to answer this now
but if you could tie other together in
each of the different accounts and I'm
assuming these are mostly dedicated
funds or something else Amy did a lot of
work on this so she can briefly and then
we could provide this but Amy knew that
this question might come so go Amy
I mean I I could it's probably best that
I provide this for you but there is a
breakdown of all of the other categories
and what exactly falls into all of those
other kind of buckets and the fees that
go into each of those but um and
different agency income but um like in
Communications um there is you know
like let me see like that we talked
about the telephone search charge
there's a lift operator fee there's a
decal Carnival equipment fee um agency
income administration fee a crial record
free goes in there so like it's Pro and
then there's um the total for each
budget year so rather than going through
every single line and every number it's
probably probably easi for me to just
provide this for you great so each of
these others May relate to different
groups of funds yes okay and always
dedicated funds or this is there
something else that's in there
that these dedicated they're all
dedicated by division she's got it broke
it it's all by division okay yep and are
the funding sources you'll provide those
as
well do they are they designed to cover
the costs for which the funds are used
so if you they are outlined in your
presentation so in the um you on one of
it's you know it's not as I'm sorry it's
not as clear on here as I was hoping I
was going to be but um in in the chart
it'll show you um exactly what division
what it covers what it's used for and
what it brings in in each fiscal year so
it'll get to your questions about um
exactly the revenue and then what what
it what it's used for right okay but I'm
also trying to understand um that's
great I definitely want all that but
understanding so it's is it intended to
address a particular
need and if so is it funded
appropriately by whatever sources of
revenue are coming into it to address
that need or we do we need to look at
that for each of the different consider
each of the different I believe it is I
believe there's a direct correlation to
it
but great great but so you think in
every case your funding is adequate in
those every one of those dedicated
funds you to give the answer right now
but well I think there's two two
questions adequate is one thing like
does it fully fund the operation or is
it like right so we could provide that
but if it's like something going to
motorcycle rider safety is it directly
related to the to the fee for that yes
so what okay yeah great I think when you
look at I think when you look at this
you'll it'll make
sense go ahead Mr LeRon I think one
thing the department could discuss is
the I think the largest other funds in
the department is the highway fund cost
of collections if maybe the department
could just explain how that works and
refresher for our returning members and
explanation for the new
DM Administration
Road cost collections to uh DMV so all a
DMV and Road tool essentially
yeah you give us one second Amy's going
to get to the right page we're going to
be talking about the road toll what they
collect and how the fees we collect at
the DMV are termed cost of collection
goes and they can share an update it
sounds like the OMB did resend the uh
memo relative to the federal fund freeze
so that conversation may be on not
relevant any longer perhaps so I think
he's just saying how much has cost a
collection and where does it
go my presentation is just not done yet
So within both our road toll Bureau as
well as at the division of motor
vehicles um all revenue that comes into
both um both within the Bureau of Road
tool and which is in the division of
administration and at the Department of
Motor Vehicles all of that Revenue that
comes in um is
into the highway funds and then um the
expenses within that um Bureau and
division are then um taken out of all of
the revenue that comes in and that is
termed as Costa collections I went
through that kind of within the um uh
DNB um kind of part of my presentation
and that's what's known as Costa
collections it's what's taken off of the
Top If if you
will and what are the expenses that come
out of the highway fund that would be
everything
from um kind of all of the
um expenses all of the expenses for to
run the
operation okay so when you're looking at
trying to go further and cut the budget
8% and and I'm not ask to speak to this
but
um what I'm curious about is for these
this highway Fund in particular I guess
but even all all the other ones as well
do some of those Revenue sources perhaps
need to be increased rather than you're
looking to say General funds where to
cut your expenses you see kind of where
I'm going with this like basically gas
tax what we're talking about right right
I don't I don't think we're prepared to
to give a recommendation on
that that's you know give a
recommendation the question is are your
costs being covered I'm not asking for
the recommendation on what to do about
it but are the costs being covered well
I think the highway fund has been pretty
um flat and the expenses are going up so
the answer is
no again I think my my presentation to
Ways and Means is next week and you'll
see the revenue flat the expenses going
up in general funds has continue to um
be put into the highway fund to uh
supplement that okay could you forward
us that presentation after you give it
that be great represent
Papi thank you Mr chairman as it happens
that was one of the uh questions you
know I wanted to understand your
perspective on which is that as you
mentioned right now you appear to have a
structural deficit in the highway fund
which of course we can assign it to one
reason or another and uh I don't want to
start that because of course you better
understand it right now
but you know short of General funds
which are a very very tough ask in this
budget cycle how do you see that being
addressed from a policy perspective if
the department was able to uh suggest
how to address this and I know you got
to be careful about telling the
legislature what they I that's not what
I'm asking for but what are the overall
approaches we should look at to try to
address the structural deficit there
without just reaching into the general
fund and uh filling it
up I mean this this budget that we're
putting forward our agency budget is
doesn't even look at that so if we
continue toing
at we've met our targets where DMV we
have it up and running it's operating um
as Amy said cost to collections funds
the buildings funds the employees funds
the equipment funds of salary funds of
benefits same thing with road toll so
this this has us operating and
continuing to operate your question is
what could be done in the future and I
don't think that that's our position to
answer that today thank you so you say
today is it
ever I mean I mean we can we we Pro we
provide we provide the data what does it
cost to run the Department of Motor
Vehicles Division of Motor Vehicles what
does it cost to run the road toll
there's Revenue that's brought
in we draw down on that revenue and I
think as Amy said what's left goes into
the highway fund okay go ahead I
appreciate it and look sometimes we ask
questions and it's perfectly okay to say
hey not my daily week that particular uh
approach right um any thoughts you have
on the uh significant amount of money
that you are asking for the fire fund
top of again it's $4 million of General
funds is a lot of money and obviously we
want to keep the place running but you
know what could we possibly do any
thoughts on how we can avoid the need
for such large general fund inflows yeah
we will continue to work with the
governor's office and her team on the
fire fund the
current state of it this budget and then
the
future thank you I'm looking forward to
seeing what comes out of that and then
we'll work on the same thing thank
you any
other
questions so I want and this is a Kudos
if I can get to the right place are you
all familiar with the intersection of 89
and Clinton Street I am okay are you
familiar with a proposal that at least
within the last couple years was for a
very large
roundabout uh situation going to change
the whole thing the whole put a big
interchange up there are you familiar
with that high level but not the
specific high level high level yeah okay
and are you familiar what's there
now I'm thinking the last time I get off
that exit it's a stoplight I would like
to know what brilliant person in your
organization finally came to the
realization that geez a stoplight would
work because it's brilliant is about 5%
of the cost if not even less and it
works fantastically so whoever came up
whoever finally got there I hope you're
given them a big award it was it wasn't
me
so but um but that that goes to I will I
will share this with you so we have a
really good team there the state police
highway safety work and I know they've
looked at a lot of of these areas but
we're continuing to focus not only on
95 from Massachusetts to Maine but
looking at all areas all stretches the
roadways where is there guardrail now
where could there be cable where and
we're looking at the data we're trying
to build and look and determine and then
really really where do we invest the
money and why and we're trying to
concentrate on Ed on the education piece
too we've done a big push on highway
safety we've got a new um uh vendor that
we're dealing with on messaging and um
so we're really really looking hard on
this for you know the safety of all of
you everywhere so it isn't just on one
road but um I will send that message
back right and it's not just looking at
at making it improving the safety but as
efficiently in sure the minimal cost and
that was what I was really right like
done yes ma'am uh uh representative D
Roy on these Road Ries that they're
putting in and I don't know if it's more
local if at state level but it IT
addresses what he's talking about that
when they're putting these rotaries in
it's costing a lot of money because they
have to buy land and they do all that
stuff when four lights might happen you
know instead of all of those rotaries
what analysis was done to determine what
what procedure to put in in order to do
that I would direct that to commissioner
Cass and his team of Engineers so
they're the ones that would do those
studies the engineering studies we share
whatever information we have on crashes
but design engineering as it relates to
safety that's uh the department of
transportations is it okay all right
thank you wheelhouse R papichi thank you
Mr chairman while while we are into the
you know grab bag portion of this where
we come up with a small questions that
were not worth of interrupting the
presentation until now would you be so
kind and give director John marasco a
heads up that we had a conversation a
couple of years ago over a
concern I had over an inspection by done
by a government inspection station and
whether they are subject to the same
safety standards and expectations as
private inspection stations could you
just remind him that we did have that
conversation and it would be great if he
could give us an update when uh he comes
up it's not directly a budget matter but
it does have to do with the operation of
the DMV and uh you know having the same
standards for private and public
inspection stations yeah so I just
wanted it's not a question as much as a
no I understand but it's a so you're
saying there's a government inspection
station I'm saying that there was a
government inspection station if you
want a bit more detail that um put a
certificate of inspection sticker or a
vehicle where the uh frame the floor of
the thing was rusted through and I
raised the concern with the director and
they had an investigation and I told him
that you know once that is over I'm not
going to follow up with him immediately
I'll just follow up and we see each
other again to save him the time of uh
you know I know he's got a busy schedule
and everything and my concern again is
that I want to make sure that the
inspection station that issued that
sticker in my opinion but I'm not the
expert and I trust the DMV
experts was a bit um easier uh you know
on in the inspection I'm I just want to
make sure they're subject to the same
standards as Just In fairness for the
for the members of the um Committee just
to um share a little is not only for
this inspection station but any
inspection station when we do get a
complaint whether it's from a a motor
vehicle stop or or an accident in a
trooper we have automotive equipment
inspectors that work through the state
police we have our Troop G uh Troopers
that are highly trained in this they do
investigations they will look at the
vehicle determine what um where it
failed to meet inspection whether it was
rust or Tire issue or emissions and then
if they are found um that they did
violate it there's a process where
there's actually a hearing that can be
conducted at the department of safety
and then it would come up to my office
on whether there should be a sanction
whether it would be uh a suspension or
enhanced training but we they pay very
close attention to this so I'll make
sure not speaking to the individual ones
but um but the oversight is not just on
one it's on it's on on all of the um
inspections and the mechanics that are
licensed to do them I know thank you
appreciate it representative Murray
thank you Mr chair uh to give you a
chance a little bit to recoup into shine
can you just give us an overview of the
improvements of the DMV I mean there
used to be blog backlogs you've gotten a
lot more infrastructure and Technology
around that um would you like to just
share your improvements with that and um
how that people are generally pretty
happy now going to the DMV for the most
part sure I will and I and I
thank you for the question um I give uh
the credit not only to uh director
morasco assistant commissioner Lavo has
been working closely with him but he's
got a great team there great team on his
licensing his registration his title but
it's a big operation but everything's
geared to customer service the phone
bank the phone cues and getting whatever
transactions can be done electronically
done electronically while balancing
Safety and Security so it's a big
operation and if if we gear it to
customer service and you're you're you
know you are our customers and John um
his motto is we work for you at the DMV
we work for you um I think that there's
more to do we're continuing to look at
we have projects right now electronic
title electronic lean he works with his
stakeholders mainly the public but we
work closely with the auto dealers on
transactions and titles and cues and
waiting because all that equates to to
the economy and business and and growth
we work closely with the uh the New
Hampshire Motor Transport trucks um are
they getting their registrations are
they getting their stamps but it's it's
time is money and of anywhere there can
be an efficiency but we don't we listen
so he brings in the stakeholders and
they're part of it so if we're going to
take State dollars and build something
build a system before we roll it out we
want to make sure that they're part of
the team and they're looking and they're
working on it so um it's a continuous
process proc though to look at the
weight times monitor it um the phones if
we've got I think director Nu spoke to
300 plus thousand minutes on the phone
now we want to look at why so is it one
process that's calling you know that's
recording is it a title issue is it how
do we so it's a continuous looking at
their um driver licensing and testing
nothing more important than the process
to get somebody license in their first
uh driver and and director morasco sends
a nice letter they created that I got my
license so it's a it's a lot he has a
lot of external stakeholders that he has
to deal with and um so we're not making
you know decisions in a vacuum over
there but he's got a good team but thank
thank you for the question and I'll pass
that along and give my best to director
okay representative duray just have one
last question and I know it's
probably uh maybe not appropriate but I
think it's important to you are you
going to be taxed on extra work when now
that they're doing um deportation of the
immigrants here in the state is that
going to put a lot of pressure on your
team there's been no decisions made and
any of those decisions would go through
you know the governor's office and so as
of this point no we are working um very
hard at the northern border um I was
just up there last week I can tell you
that uh um we've got over 150 officers
that help
and they're working within those 25 air
miles of the Border but there's a lot of
activity in Pittsburgh there's a lot of
people going up there tourism
snowmobiles there a lot that happens on
those Trails so the local Chief uh the
county sheriff fishing game the dncr
they're all working together we've got a
good team up there and um and it
enhances Public Safety I mean we really
I've said it we have law enforcement
where there was little law enforcement
so we're continuing to do that but we
will um we will continue to wait and see
um what changes take place but as of
right now there's no there's been no it
could be from a monetary perspective as
well you know Manpower and monetary that
it could affect you we can generally
adjust to whatever yeah um we are
required to
do we all
said thank you both it was excellent
present thank you for the questions and
I've been taking notes and we'll get
everything that you asked for through Mr
land perfect that'd be great thank you
2:19
e
we'll open the division 2 Finance
meeting with the Department of
Transportation and please bring forward
whoever wants to come
and that on good afternoon everyone um
thank you Mr chairman for uh having us
uh I'm Bill Cass the commissioner of the
Hampshire dot with me is Danielle
Shandra our um Director of Finance um
and behind us is um Dave rodrig who's
the assistant commissioner and chief
engineer and Steve lante who's our uh
legislatively aison
could you spell your assist oh not your
assistant the the name of the woman
sitting beside you spell it spell the
name last name CH h a n d o n n e t yeah
that did you did you spell it like the
wine I I it kind of sounded that way so
I was close yes pretty
close uh thank you proceed so um we were
asked uh this isn't our budget
presentation we were asked to come and
give kind of an overview of the
department an introduction to the
department and kind of outline the
sources of funding so that's kind of an
introduction and that's the presentation
that we have through here I'm going to
step through it oh go ahead perfect oh
okay thank you I'm going to step through
it pretty quickly it's meant as a
resource is a probably a lot more
information so don't go too quickly so
we can keep up with you all right I I I
was going to say I Pro my my goal would
be to just kind of touch on elements
there's more information there to take
back and reference uh but certainly as
we go uh please interrupt please stop
and ask questions uh as we go so um and
I do I I tend to go fast because I want
to be uh respectful of the committee's
time but um yeah so please just
interrupt if there are any questions or
flag me if I'm dragging on too long so
you won't go too long that's that's not
a concern um so on page one is just
overview of the Department's Mission and
purpose so at nhdot we work hard every
day to provide transportation excellence
and enhance the quality of life for
people in New Hampshire and our purpose
that's a that's a wordy statement you
can read but I I look at that uh really
we're here to provide quality
transportation services and projects in
a safe efficient and timely manner so
that's our primary
purpose slide two is a is a kind of an
organizational structure just to give
you a sense of how the dot is organized
and our budget is also reflected around
this organization so I'm the
commissioner underneath me there are uh
two uh two other Commissioners assistant
commissioner and chief engineer Dave
rodrig who's here today and uh the
Deputy Commissioner under the
commissioner and the commissioner's
office we have five divisions each
division is headed by a uh
director and uh the director and those
five divisions are are are highlighted
there we also have put a lot of focus
and emphasis on on safety so we have had
a safety office that um that we've
elevated to be a direct report to the
commissioner's office um because I feel
safety is really a cross-cutting issue
it doesn't fit under one division it
should be cross cross divisional and
cross cutting and we also have an asset
management performance strategies um
office that is again a direct report to
the commissioner's
office um the various bureaus underneath
the divisions are are are listed there
and then a little bit more in depth in
the uh presentation I'll um highlight
some of those some of those
divisions so on the next slide is uh a
general overview of of the budgeted
positions the positions and trends for
the department so the top graph show
those are
historical budgeted full-time positions
going back about 20 years um and the red
line is vehicle miles traveled it's an
indication it's a metric of the use of
of the system and um you can see that
you know over time particularly in
around the
2013 to 2014 budget cycle um we have had
Workforce reductions we have um reduced
Personnel um it's been generally level
since around
2014 but we have continued to see uh
increasing vehicle miles traveled
y I apologize for interrupting but I I
would appreciate it if you'd remind me
CU I'm sure you told me this two years
ago how do you guys measure the vehicle
miles traveled what's the source of
information that you use to get to those
numbers yep the source of uh information
is uh we do um we do traffic counts all
over the state um um there's a regular
systematic program of of uh measuring
traffic volumes and that's aggregated
and uh it's a it's a metric that we
report to Federal Highway all 50 states
reported the Federal Highway so it's
based on
that um so the bottom line of that and
and well well let me take a step back
the bottom chart represents uh a a more
near term in the last 10 years of so of
budgeted versus filled positions and the
green line shows our vacancy rate um and
we have since postco at the agency um
have been experiencing uh you know
Workforce shortages and a um vacancy
rate of around 20 to
25% um despite our best efforts we have
continued to um have difficulties
filling positions and stuff my point in
this slide is is to is as I think that
it indicates that we as an agency
continue to do more with less in my mind
it's a it's a it's a illustration of the
efficiency that that we uh have and that
we Embrace we continue to get things
done maybe not as much as we would like
to but even with fewer positions even
with the vacancy rates we still tend to
get our core Mission done so we continue
to more do more with less representative
Murray thank you sorry for interrupting
but um since we right here can you give
a description of the workforce shortages
which which um positions are not being
filled um it's this is an aggregate for
the for the Department as a whole we
found primarily in in some of the
professional development Fields so um
two main areas that that we have chronic
shortages are in our engineering series
um which more falls on the division of
project development and our Highway
maintainer series those are kind of some
of the lower paid um um positions and
that's exacerbated by most of those
positions require um um commercial
driver's licenses and there's a a
nationwide kind of shortage of CDL
Drivers as well too so that that all
exacerbates but in those two areas are
where we find the most chronic
shortages yeah you're welcome
just just continuing that thought so the
problem persisted and got worse
postco do is there anything you
attribute that to is that a national
problem or um we I I put it that we
never really recovered and never came
back from from covid so we had a
year plus long um hiring free at the
state during during Co so that was uh
probably a precipitating uh cost but
then coming out of Co Workforce Dynamics
had changed um certainly the uh number
of remote uh you know people working
remotely that that we have um that we're
not quite as flexible with and um I
think the competitive W wages as well
particularly at those lower um um wage
rates we saw a lot of inflation and
stuff coming out of covid and coming
back back in the State uh we did have a
10% um pay raise
in uh two years ago 2 and a half years
ago um a lot of that was you know really
kind of made up for um or or not quite
made up for the inflation that was being
seen at the time I don't know Danielle
do you have something else to add I do
in addition to those things there's high
demand for those positions elsewhere so
on the on the highway maintainer side
municipalities are are also looking for
the same kind of position so there are
options for employees on the engineering
side what we're finding is there are
fewer graduates of of in civil
engineering and a great demand for it so
there there are great there are
Consultants uh consultant agencies so
there's a lot of different options for
employees aside from the state
representative piji thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for answering
questions just to clarify what you just
said uh I'm assuming you have some wage
studies wage comparisons on how we Faire
you know in paying for the same type of
job versus municipalities or other
states we may be competing with
something to shed just a little bit of
light we don't want to Del overly de
deeply but just to get an understanding
overall if you could share that at a
later point that would be great
certainly yeah thank you I
do no thank you very much for the for
the for the interesting questions um
moving ahead the the next slide just
gives some facts and figures about the
dot so you just get a general sense of
the side of the um size of the agency
and the uh breadth of our coverage so we
have about
1,650 uh full-time permanent positions
um budgeted as I said they're not all
they're not all fold we're we're dealing
with a approximately a 23 to 25% vacancy
rate we maintain uh
2159 State Bridges we inspect every
bridge in the state that includes the
other 1,700 or so Municipal Bridges um
can you provide lists those two lists
the state red list and the municipal red
list to Mr Lander again yes certainly Y
and I believe um yes we as
spreadsheets yes yes no we do I LW I I'm
just thinking the law had changed uh
several years ago we do a annual report
it goes to the governor's office I
believe it goes to like the speaker of
the house and the and the and the and
the um president of the Senate but we
can certainly get it to the uh
commission I know we provide it to our
policy committee house Public Works and
stuff so um that's available and we'll
get it to them to you
yep um the next page again I don't want
to belabor it uh there's just um you
know a uh some of those key facts we do
have a a a lot of miles of roadway and
pavement and and other ancillary um uh
traffic hardware and impertinences that
we are uh that it's that it's our
mission and that we're responsible for
maintaining uh we also uh maintain about
194 miles of active state-owned railroad
lines and uh we administer and
distribute funding that supports 25
publicly accessible airports and 11
local public transit systems so in One
Way Or Another We're um involved in
Touching with all modes of
transportation in the
state the um the next slide about dot
fun funding sources um I don't want to
read it but I'm going to spend a little
bit of time here because this really
does kind of explain the um the basis of
the Department's
funding um so our budget has
Appropriations for uh four from four
fund from four sources of funding
um these are going to be a general
overview and as I get into some of the
further presentation division by
division I'll um fill in a little bit
more about where and how it fits in and
how it's implement mented but um as a
general overview um federal funds we
receive federal funds and federal
revenue from several different agencies
primarily focused on what mode of
transportation they they support um so
we get funding from fhwa which supports
the surface Transportation program FTA
which supports uh transit systems FAA
which supports the aeronautic um the uh
the airport and those aeronautic
Services um FTA and FAA we don't have a
lot of Hands-On
um uh implementation of those funds we
are generally a pass through but our
agency is the uh State administer of
those funds so those funds flow through
us to other agencies they flow through
us through our budget and you'll see
those um on the um and and one thing to
point out that all of these federal
funds are are typically restricted to
certain uses in certain modes um so um
it is a little Nuance as we talk about
our our budget and and and things
because even though they're general fund
federal funds um we cannot Flex Federal
Transit funds to use for highways and
bridges and so forth and most of the
federal funds particularly the F fhwa
Federal Highway funds they are
restricted to capital projects only we
cannot use federal funds for operations
and and maintenance activities and all
of these federal funds require some sort
of State match and how that match is um
met um varies um varies by uh a number
of the modes and and how they're
administered and I'll get into that in a
little bit more detail
later the next source of funds we
receive and we utilize are Highway funds
and the highway funds are the primary
source of revenue for our operations and
maintenance as I pointed out earlier we
can't use federal funds for maintenance
so uh that falls to the state highway
fund um that also is uh a source of
funds through that we um distribute
block grant Aid to
municipalities um and and it goes
towards the debt service on our capital
projects and the revenue that's
generated from the highway fund comes
primarily through the road toll uh the
gas tax and vehicle registration
fees and the use of um Highway funds is
restricted by the state constitution to
specifically surface
Transportation the um third set of funds
that we use as the turnpike funds
Turnpike funds uh come from the um not
the road toll but the toll plazas and
the toll booths on the turnpike system
um that's the primary source of funding
for capital projects operations and
maintenance on a small subset of our
freeways that are that comprise the uh
Turnpike system and the Turnpike system
is an enterprise system which means that
it is supported by the toll Revenue that
comes in for it and that toll Revenue
can only be used on the turnpike system
it can't be used for other Highway and
Bridge needs around the state um and
I'll get into that in a little bit more
detail and finally I'm sure you've heard
a lot more from other agencies about
General funds we have a very small
portion of our operating budget um
that's uh supported by the general funds
um it's primarily goes toward the
nonsurface transportation areas uh
including Personnel cost and Aeronautics
uh Rail and
Transit
um and general funds in the past and
past budgets have been used to support
and to to sort of bail out the highway
fund there have been infusions of
General funds into the highway fund to
um um to meet uh to meet budget
needs and finally uh even though it's
not necessarily part of our operating
budget under hb25 is the capital budget
um we look at the primary the the
primary use for um we and I bring that
up here because the capital funds the
hb25 it is a source of some of the match
for some of those
um uh Transit and Aeronautics uh
projects so the state match for uh some
of the transit and uh Aeronautics uses
comes from the um capital
budget any questions on the general
things uh before I move ahead just one
who actually controls the highway fund
is it your department or the one we just
saw uh I a long answer to that would
probably be the legislature so it
controls it yeah okay uh I we do say and
I have something down here father the
dot despite the despite the highway and
and the name we're not the highway fund
and uh and the highway fund is not the
do so the highway fund is um is is where
revenue from um gas tax and um uh motor
vehicle registration fees flow into and
it's approp op at out by uh by the
legislature to various State agencies
the dot is uh one of the bigger
recipients of IT department of safety is
the uh Second and um and then also to
municipalities and I have a little bit
more detail in that but Department of
Safety collects the revenue
um and uh they necessar appropriated by
so I I highlighted the uh four sets of
funds just in uh the next Slide the
funding summary the types of funds it
gives you just uh a highlevel breakout
of of how much of of each of those funds
are in our in our in our budget so um
primarily the overall budget is uh the
biggest percentage is the federal funds
on the bottom there in blue the second
um biggest share of funding is the is
the highway Fund in in the middle and I
would just point to the little green
line in the middle there about 2 or. 3%
that that constitutes the um M you know
minor amount of General funds that
support those non-surface Transportation
bureaus on the following Slide the pie
charts it gives a little bit more of a
breakdown um and it helps us to explain
and and and sort out this bigger budget
in a in a way so we tend to look at our
budget in two major parts um the bigger
slice on the on the left we call
Municipal Aid and construction a lot of
that is the federal funds that flow
through our budget and go to the
construction programs that go to the aid
to the city of towns that go to the um
Transit agencies that go to the to the
um to the airport type of project so
that um is all we can I consider it more
more pass through and it's primarily F
Federal Federal um federal funds on on
that slice of the pie on the rightand
side is the operating budget and um
that's about 46 48% of our overall state
budget um and that is the operating cost
of our staff of our Personnel of the
equipment of the resources needed to
maintain and um operate the
transportation system so on the where
where the municipal Aid and construction
primarily constitutes the federal funds
that we receive the operating budget is
primarily funded by the by the highway
fund um one other point I would make uh
that a lot of our budget discussion even
though all of these funds are part of
our budget most of the budget
discussions at this time of year are
focused around the operating budget um
and where we have uh more discretion to
make make uh make changes and and um
where the driving um budgetary needs are
met the municipal Aid in construction um
a lot of the choices of where funds are
investment invested in types of projects
and specific projects um even though the
dollars flow through our budget a lot of
that is decided in the off budget year
when we uh take up the uh banal update
of the state's 10-year Transportation
program so
hopefully that adds a little context and
breakdown of the overall budget and the
percentages of the budget are shown
there as well
too so the from from here I was going to
kind of break it down I had noted that
we have five divisions uh and I I kind
of take it division by division uh
because each division has you know their
own kind of funding source and and
things like that so that's that's where
we're at now and I'll give you from an
introduction just a general overview of
each division As It Go so the um so the
next two slides uh the top one gives a
brief summary of the division of
Aeronautics Rail and Transit um it's
made up of three bureaus Aeronautics
which um help support the funding and
and administers the funding and the FAA
grants to the 12 federally funded
airports and there's some facts and
figures there about the Aeronautics
bureo uh the rail Bureau um that um uh
ad administers and and oversees the six
Active uh operating agreements and the
194 miles of active state-owned Rail and
finally the public transit um Bureau
which oversees and administers the FTA
funds uh to the 11 local public transit
agencies and systems there is one um one
uh bus service that that the state
administers fairly directly and that is
is the Boston Boston express route the
commuta service that we run on the i93
quarter uh between Manchester and
airports the um I can get you a list of
them but the uh well what what what does
it mean that they're block rain airport
so New Hampshire is a little bit unique
in in the state that that we have black
Grant so we essentially serve as FAA in
administering those those funds so funds
from FAA come to New Hampshire and in
blocks and we administer them to the um
federal aid eligible airports other
states other states uh most of those
airports are dealing directly with with
FAA on the administration of those funds
so this basically private airports no
these are these are mun these are
typically Municipal public owned Public
Access airports oh okay and the three
that do have direct um um interactions
with with FAA are the three commercial
airports which are Lebanon uh peas and
Manchester Boston Regional Airport the
other um I don't have a full list of the
10 block 10 block grant airports but the
other um like con public airports like
conquered yeah conquered lonia um
Keen I'd have to see Sky Haven is a
little bit different because that's
under the PDA but um Baki see pardon me
the ice
airport the ice P airport is not a
federal aid eligible airport but uh It
Is overseen by uh by our Aeronautics
Bureau you're right yeah yeah thank you
you're
welcome um and there are like say on on
that there are 12 airports that do not
receive federal aid those would be like
the ice airport um I up in my area of
the woods Plymouth is much more of a of
a of a landing strip there are a number
of those smaller airports that don't
requirements
sure and uh on the final slide is just
some facts and figures there a little
bit more of a breakdown of the uh costs
under the Aeronautics Rail and Transit
um and you can see that that 2% of the
general fund this is this is where it
kind of goes about 1.8 million that that
that goes to the Personnel costs um in
this this Bureau um as I said a lot of
this is passed through Federal funding
as a primary
um um source of revenue for Aeronautics
uh and Transit programs uh these those
bureaus administer those
um and um I would point out that all of
these uh Federal funding do require a
match and as I said the FAA funds are
are matched with capital funds Transit
State match is budgeted uh with General
funds um that is contained in in our
budget um most of the transit match um
falls on the local operating systems and
the um cities and towns that operate
those those operating those transit
systems representative Pap V thank you
Mr chair just a quick question you
mentioned earlier that Boston Express is
mostly operated by us mhm I probably
should have remembered that from two
years ago but could you please just give
me a quick explanation as to why we're
doing that I'm presuming that we have an
interest in ensuring easy transportation
to Boston and back but why are we you
know involved with Boston Express yeah
part of it was the the the big the big
gist of it came from when we were
building um Interstate 93 when that i93
widening project came along it was a
commitment to um during the construction
phase to um support um alternative modes
of transportation and and support um
commuta bus service to help alleviate
some of the traffic impacts during
Construction Construction for i93 went
on for eight eight or nine years and it
really became a um um dependent upon
service when when i93 was completed the
construction was completed um through
the a plan process it was decided that
uh there was value to the continued
commuter um bus service in that Corridor
um so it so it has continued as a state
um supported
um uh service you're
welcome private service in the quarter
primarily serves um Logan Airport our
focus is is on commuter bus service
supporting commuters from uh from New
Hampshire to the Boston Regional area
so sure by all means uh one of the
things that I wanted to add here is um
we are seeing some additional pressures
for additional general fund revenue for
this this small group tied to um
additional expense burdens that are
related to benefits and overhead and
indirect charges that are caused that
are charged to that area and not a lot
of place to find those that funding and
so we are not able to get that funding
um we would maximize any federal funding
if it was available to use for those
things but they're not and so the only
other source of funding that we would
have would be General funds and we've
seen increases pretty significant
increases in benefits and indirect costs
um that we're having uh a little bit of
a difficult time funding and would
require some additional General funds
and could you detail this not right now
make um moving moving on um a little bit
more detail on the next slot next two
slides about uh project development
Bureau and the revenue overview so
project development is the um division
that uh really administers the Federal
Highway funds and really um um
administers our um construction program
for roads and bridges so all the
planning design permitting property
Acquisitions construction oversight um
falls under uh project development
Bureau um and the federal funds along
with the restricted Highway funds are
the primary revenue sources for uh for
that Division and for that uh for those
projects and as I said earlier a lot of
those decisions around um levels of
investment and Paving and bridges and
which which which uh projects um get
funded uh is contained in the 10-year
Transportation plan uh that gets updated
every every two years and that will be
starting this this summer uh and and
come to the legislature next next
session but in in general um orders of
magnitude we receive about 225 million
doll a year in Federal Highway funds
that support that that
program um and it goes towards the
development and oversight of Highway and
Bridge designs the Environmental
Compliance right of way
acquisition uh some of those funds are
uh passed through to uh some Municipal
uh Aid projects uh dealing with cities
and towns and uh we oversee all of the
um all of the state construction as as
well too so that $225 million a year
that's what we call our formula funds
that's the apportionment from from
Federal Highway way um there are
additional funds that can come that can
flow into that depending on you know how
the federal program is going any one one
year um in the last few days with some
of the um um executive orders and stuff
you may have heard about a discretionary
grants and things put putting on hold
but that is that is uh you know
additional Revenue if we uh compete for
uh certain discretionary grants and
things like that that's another uh area
that gets funded um and every year
there's also a um a redistribution of
federal funds that happens every year um
other states that aren't able to use all
of their Federal allotment um it gets
turned in and redistributed to other
states we have uh in the last several
years been um fortunate enough to be
poised and ready with projects that
we've been able to utilize you know in
the order of 30 to $33 million
additional um federal funds through re
redistribution every year so um that's a
broad uh overview in in the general
amount of of of funding and I mentioned
that about some of the additional um
funds because the total revenue on the
on the following slide flowing through
uh project development is about $373
million um the biggest part of that is
the federal funds but there are also
restricted State funds as well as
Turnpike Capital funds that go into that
construction program as well too um
um and uh one thing i' I'd point out I I
I reiterate again that these federal
funds can't be used for uh maintenance
or operation so it's very much dedicated
to the construction
program but um even in light of that we
do try out of necessity and and and and
um just one second sure can you make
sure it's not locked so that people can
get
yeah good perfect I'm sorry I didn't
didn't notice thank you and thank you
for the interuption
yeah um I was about the the third bullet
down on that on that slide talking about
direct and indirect federal revenue
reimbursements but um we try to leverage
the fund the the federal funds as as
much as we can to um to support our
operating needs and lessen the burden
and lessen the impact on the on the
highway fund um primarily out of out of
out of necessity so um you know some of
the direct and indirect Federal uh
funding um we other states don't but we
do a an indirect cost assessment uh
looking at all our administrative costs
and everything that support the federal
program and um we um
we uh I'm gonna say it colloquially
Danielle could probably say it better
but we we put a we put a 10% charge we
we take uh 10% for toward our um
indirect cost of of every Federal dollar
that we that we Bild um is that the
right way to put it yeah it is so every
year we are required to provide an
indirect cost um analysis to the federal
government and it it depend you know
there's a formula and it depends on the
the um charges that we've had in certain
areas and we have typically um been
approved for a 10% indirect cost rate
that indirect cost rate pays for
salaries it pays for salaries for
support staff people who are doing
billing HR any kind of any kind of
position that would be in the support of
a federal program those positions are
generally multif funded and by that I
mean they would be funded by indirect
fed costs they would be funded by
Turnpike um Turnpike dollars and they
would be funded by Highway fund dollars
as well that's what I mean by by multif
funded right so it get it does get a
little complicated but we do try to
leverage those those federal funds we
also have direct budgeted uh um federal
funds in various operating bureaus uh
that support um primarily project
development if they are um working on on
a federal aid project and they're
billing directly to to to that uh
project for the engineering or the
construction oversight we do um we do
direct budget those federal funds to
support those costs so what is the
lesses available for funding additional
projects mean comparatively other states
uh
will will utilize all of their
construction fund all of their federal
funds strictly for construction and and
they will um they will fund the match
they will fund uh those indirect costs
they will fund um those um Personnel
positions that are doing that work with
with State funds um we we've had a lot
of projects with with Vermont Interstate
projects with Vermont in in Maine and
and it's created some interesting
discussions because we we we talk to
them and we we we go to build them that
that 10% indirect rate and and they uh
they really don't know what we're
talking about because they because again
they don't administer their federal
funds the same way
so Murray yeah thank you since we're on
that I think we're it's in sort of the
same vein we use tax credits to collect
to to match for federal funds whereas a
lot of the other states um the money
comes directly from the government
they're not using tax credits they're
using State funds for that and so
basically we don't get the value of 100%
of the federal dollars because it we
have to use the tax credits for that so
can you speak since we're on that topic
can you just speak a little bit and I
forget what that thing is called it's
the very next bullet I was just getting
to that so you it's actually called uh
Turnpike toll credits um so again yeah
most every uh Federal dollar comes with
a matching requirement most of the
Federal Highway fund dollars are match
20% um so it's 80% Federal 20% State
match um um we have leveraged the
investment of State funds Turnpike funds
uh that go into the turnpike system and
we are able to um utilize those funds
and claim a credit Federal Highway
recognizes that credit and allows us to
use that credit as a as a match to the
federal program so it's not funding but
it is a credit so it allows us to use
those federal funds at um at a at a 100%
rate versus an 80% rate with a 20% match
um it limits I think what you were
getting at representative it does our
our federal funds don't go as far
because we are spending them at 100%
versus at 80% with a 20% match but so in
the upshot of of this is you know we put
very little State funds into our our
federal program um it's good for the
state budget it's it's good for meeting
the highway fund needs um it does have
some limitations on on the amount of
particularly um vulnerable or
susceptible to uh changes in federal
funding so um particularly some of the
discussions that have been going on this
week about um you know potential halts
to you know Federal Federal
dispersements and stuff like that
we are very much at the mercy of that
because we have no State funds to back
that up so that that's some of the
nuances
there um there aren't any further
questions going on there are some
restricted Highway funds that go into to
support our Capital program um and those
are listed there at the bottom 2. Cent
2.6 cents of the of the gas tax goes to
the um betterment program which is used
primarily for theay saving program and
we utilize that for um nonfederal Aid uh
State highways so about a third of our
state highway mileage because their
lower tier roads or unnumbered state
roads are uh not eligible for federal
aid so we depend on the betterment funds
for the paving and upkeep and
maintenance of those roads so I'm
guessing that's RSA specified these the
better stuff no it's actually a uh
Federal uh requirement based on the
classification of of the of the of the
road Federal F Federal classification
yeah um there's also uh block rant Aid
that's uh about 12% of the of the um of
the road toll um that that by Statute uh
is distributed to cities and towns it's
approximately $35 million a year that
flows through our our budget and we
disperse that to the cities and towns
and uh there is also um a restricted
portion of the gas tax
um that that got passed under SB 367 in
2014 that was uh intended to pay for the
i93 widening project we had um borrowed
some money from a Federal Loan program
to complete the construction of i93 with
the pledge of this 4.2 Cent gas tax
increase to pay back those those loans
um so um that is a restricted area of
that and and one of the reasons I bring
that up and the the waterfall is shown
on the on the next slide
um you said intended did did did you was
there an implication there that it
wasn't used for that
purpose that was the intent of of
passing the bill and the bill was passed
yes so that's what it um yeah sorry if I
misspoke but that's what it is used for
now um so for the last 10 years or so we
have only the way the the way the loan
and the uh waterfall was structured
we've only been paying um interest on
the on the debt service on on the bonds
and the remaining uh money from that has
gone to um rural Paving and and and and
bridges um so for the last 10 years
we've had about $20 million of of State
funds from that 4.2 Cent gas tax
increase that has gone to uh Paving and
and Bridge repair um I bring this up now
because in this fiscal year in this
budget um we have to begin paying the um
the full Debt Service for the i93
project for the next um 10 years or so
and the um the 10 years of uh about $20
million a year that we have
had the flexibility to invest in um
roads and bridges um that money is now
going to Debt Service uh and that's
reflected in our budget and and stuff
and it is something we will be
discussing through the 10-year plan
process how to make up that um
um what I perceive what well that
shortfall with other federal funds and
stuff but it is a little bit of a Nuance
but it is reflected in our budget this
year that change in how the s sp36 funds
are used I'm sure there was a a reason
for that going back was there when this
began was there something else that was
going on that we were paying the 20
million towards in this words why did we
wait until now to do this was it an
arbitrary number we chose number of
years
or I was it was a structuring it it was
the most advantageous to the state to um
to be able to only pay debt service and
it was a very low interest uh loan that
that we received so um I think the
structure of it it was uh in the state's
best interest to be able to Avail
ourselves of of of the use of that
revenue for the intervening years and
and was low interest for only that
limited period of time whatever it's
been 20 years or something right it's
1.09% for the loan and so it was
structured deliberately to be able to
provide that service um for for uh
Paving and Bridge repair to the rural SE
um sections that was a deliberate act um
and it allowed those those things to
happen Federal Loan I assume say again a
Federal Loan the it is a Federal Loan
representative papich thank you Mr
chairman just to clarify what I hear you
say is that the interest rate was fixed
on the loan at
1.09% we just made a decision because it
was almost free money in terms of
interest to just stretch the repayment
as much as we can to get to basically
decrease the present value money of what
yeah so moving on the next uh the next
slide and this is very limited and
hopefully I can explain it uh talks
about the turnpike fund revenue and uh
it's probably easiest to explain what
the turnpike system is and and and isn't
so the turnpike system comprises three
segments of freeway um freeway uh
highways so I95 over in the Sea Coast
that runs from Seabrook to uh
Portsmouth um even though it's
Interstate 95 it is a Turnpike supported
by the toll plaza in Hampton the
Spalding Turnpike that runs from
Portsmouth up to up to Milton is uh
likewise uh part of the turnpike system
is supported by the um the toll plazas
in um in uh Dover and Rochester and the
central Turnpike even though it is I 93
for most of the part of it uh the
central New Hampshire Turnpike and then
the Fe Everett Turnpike going down
through NASA uh is a central New
Hampshire Turnpike again supported by
the toll plazas in Bedford and in and in
hookit so um the overall Turnpike system
is about 89 miles long comprises 172
Bridges seven toll plazas and we have
about 180 positions in the turnpike uh
Bureau that uh uh support the operation
and maintenance um and it's an
Enterprise fund so that by RSA all the
toll Revenue that comes to support those
systems can only be used on those on
those Road roadways um it can't be used
for other highways in the state um and
does it cover all the expenses of the
turnpike system it does cover all the
expenses of the turnpike system and when
was the last time the tolls were
increased the last time the tolls were
increased were were in
2009 so and what is the current toll it
by Plaza yeah I know but so give me some
samples it's generally a dollar yeah 75
cents I think on the Spalding Turnpike
uh Hampton is
250 yeah I have to look might be yeah
could be
today represent papichi I'm
sorry thank you Mr chairman I'm gonna
piggy back on this fun toll discussion
for a slightly different question which
is not quite budget but uh it's closing
out
there have been bills last term
introduced to get rid of the front
license plates and the major opposition
was that we would lose toll Revenue
because our license readers that the
tolls are for the front plate now the
tolls are
self-funded could you guys as part of
the budget process provide an estimate
of how much of a toll increase how many
cents would we need to increase the
tolls if we wanted to pay for whatever
it costs to avoid the need to have front
l plate readers read them from the back
or use whatever other mechanism the
state has or maybe just an analysis of
the revenue that we would lose to people
who don't have front place because we
already have cars from out of state that
pass through that sure now I don't want
to make this into a big policy
discussion but I would really appreciate
some insight as part of the budget
process of how can we we remove that
very bluntly to a lot of people an
knowing requirement of having a front
license plate that does not seem to be
really needed for safety but for this
Revenue MH I mean even on my car I had
to have you know it's a poor Mazda 3 and
the front bumper did not have a place of
to put a license plate so you drill
holes through a tiny plastic bumper it's
it's kind of a ridiculous thing we're
doing and I do want to be differential
to the needs of the turnpike system and
make sure that we don't put an undue
burden on them but it's not the big
priority in any way sure but I'm I'm
done I just wanted to share that thought
and say that I would appreciate any
feedback you could give on us if it's at
all possible because it's a tiny little
you let me let him respond and then it's
in line
ex
okay um many of my constituents have
foreign cars and a lot of the cars that
are being made now don't have a place
for this plate and so as he's talking
about they have to drill holes in which
they don't want to drill in $100,000
cars so I just thought share that with
you
um yeah um I know we testified against
it we had raised the concern I don't
think it was defeated or wasn't
supported primarily because of that I
think law enforcement had other other um
uh concerns as well too uh it is not a I
I believe and I'm sure we did a fiscal
note I'm sure we did a fiscal impact I I
I don't I think it was a substantial
amount of of Revenue I think the point
we made is we use not just the front
plate we we
take we we take pictures of of of of of
both and sometimes the back is obscured
sometimes the front in is obscured
sometimes a vehicle is pulling a trailer
and you can't see the back backl so we
use it it does it does help us with that
but I think it's a very a relatively uh
small um part but we can get you that
information as far as I'm I'm going to
lead this into another question as far
as what you said about can we look at
rates and stuff like that one of the
things getting back to Chairman or if
your your question is it is the
turnpike uh paying for itself so the
middle of that um slide there um talks
about the T Pike toll Revenue pays for
and um and it's kind of set up in that
in that um order of priority so we first
and for we we first have to use the uh
the turnpike toll Revenue to pay the
debt service pay the do Bond Bond
holders for past debts we have to pay
for the operating and maintenance cost
we have to pay for the RNR work which is
the general upkeep uh routine Paving um
keeping things in good working order RNR
stands for rehabilitation and
restoration and after all of that is
done and paid for do we put Turnpike
Revenue into Capital Improvement
projects and um I I'm going to picky
back on what you said about about rates
and stuff because coming up in the next
10-year plan we have had
Turnpike um Turnpike Revenue well let me
put it this way inflation operating
costs everything has been going up
Turnpike toll revenue is moderately up
but it hasn't kept pace with with
inflation and some of those other cost
um um cost drivers at the result of that
Capital Improvement projects continue to
get pushed out and um we have several in
the 10-year plan several um substantial
capital projects that uh are are are not
being able to be funded expansion of uh
i93 and uh through bow and conquered
here uh reconstruction of exit six and
seven in the Manchester area are a
couple of the major um capital projects
so with that you know through the
10-year plan process we can be looking
at you know these cop capital projects
if they are needed if they needed and if
they're desired this is what they cost
this is what it would take to to fund
them um and see if there is support for
a toll increase to support those if not
if there isn't the appetite for those we
will continue to pay the debt service
operate and maintain and keep the system
up but the capital projects won't be
able to be funded so I know you've been
doing that next year for sure but could
you provide us with a list of those so
the immediate Pro not immediate but the
the first project that you would pick
off that are being pushed out yes
represent Murray thank you Mr chair uh
since we're on tolls didn't correct me
if I'm wrong didn't the Bedford toll go
away no no Bedford is still there
because they was trying they were hoping
it would go we just we just let a
contract to um again that's an old the
to Plaza that needed some uh uh
Rehabilitation work and through through
the process what it's going to be
converted to all electronic tolling so
the to very similar to like in the uh uh
in the Sea Coast with uh or in
Massachusetts where most of the Mass
Turnpike has been converted to all
electronic tolling uh there won't be a
toll plaza where you can um pay cash it
will all be um um all electronic tolling
with with a Gantry um you can either pay
by plate or or pay by Easy Pass I just
remember there was a I think it was a
Senate bill to make that toll plaza go
away Bedford people
didn't marac went away marac went away
marac have been eliminated okay do you
know what that cost you to lose that
toll revenue or did you just add it on
to the other
tolls I I do we have it I don't know it
off the top of my head but
yeah
yeah so that's the that's the turnike
system again it is a the the funding is
shown in there but it is an Enterprise
System we have um um and and that
funding can't be used for other other
needs
so a representative Papi thank thank you
and just to make sure I understand
correctly the revenue is not limited
within the turnpike system you know it's
not assigned to this part or that part
whatever Revenue you get from anywhere
you can use in any other corner but it
is limited to the turn bike system
itself that's exactly right thank you
just making sure I understand correctly
I appreciate it
yeah um the the final few slides are
kind of a general overview of the
highway fund uh we had some of the talk
about that before um Highway fund
revenue is unrestricted Revenue uh and
again that's a primary source of funding
for Dot's operations and maintenance um
and and and like I said I've uh
emphasized that that uh operations and
maintenance are typically generally not
eligible for federal funding so um
operations and maintenance uh for the
for that Operations Division within the
department it consists of about 965
positions um and those are the folks
that are responsible for the Highway
Maintenance um plowing all the roads
keeping uh keeping the upkeep of those
roads um we are Statewide in the Highway
Maintenance we have six districts
regionally throughout the state and
about 87 Patrol sheds so um facilities
uh ac across the state um Bridge
maintenance traffic Mechanical Services
that supports the fleet um folks may not
know that that that the dot maintains
the state fuel distribution um uh system
um and also our transportation systems
and management uh Transportation Systems
management operations that's the
transportation management center um
which which monitors the um traffic and
utilization of the system so that's a
very uh broad overview of of of
operations but all of that what they're
um responsible for on the following
slide is a general you know kind of some
of the summary about the highway fund
Revenue overview and as we said at the
beginning when you asked the question we
you know the dot is not um is not the
highway fund and the highway fund is not
the dot it's the um Highway fund revenu
is generated from from from gas tax road
toll and and registration fees um it's
collected by the um Department of Safety
and it's attrib it's appropriated out to
the various um uses um the current road
toll the current gas tax is about 22.2
cents about 13.2 of that cents falls
into the unrestricted Revenue bucket the
other um uses are restricted to as I
said the municipal block grant Aid the
betterment program and the 4.2 cents
that goes toward um paying off
i93 um and of the motor vehicle fees
again 12 12% of that uh goes to uh
Municipal Aid and uh the remainder flows
into the uh unrestricted Highway fund um
excuse me represent
papichi Mr chair I I hope I didn't jump
the gun a bit early but sure I just
wanted to make sure at some point on
this slide you'll offer some thoughts on
the impact of the increase in electric
vehicles uh registered on the highway
find and all that sorry if I uh came in
too early and I stole the Thunder but I
really want to make sure it's covered
thank you I'll get through it real quick
for for reference of the committee the
the the split and the draw of of the
highway fund usage by the agencies is
laid out there so about 73% of uh and
this is governed by RSA as well too um
by RSA um do um draws about 73% of the
highway fund and that includes the 12%
that we distribute to um um cities and
towns and about 26% of the highway fund
Revenue goes to Department of Safety and
a small percentage 1% goes to other
agencies so that's that's the split and
the breakdown
um with with respect to your your
question due to um and and there's a
little block there on the side where we
reference that um essentially Highway
fund revenue for the last couple of
years in in this bium is is flat is
projected to be um flat um and over the
long term increases in fuel efficiency
increases in um electric vehicles uh
things like that um will have a slow
incrementals projected to have a slow
incremental decline of the overall uh
Revenue into the highway fund
historically fuel efficiency and things
have have been made up by ever
increasing um volumes of of of traffic
that that VMT figure that vehicle miles
traveled um but um uh you know through
the 80s and 90s that that type of
continued growth has very much leveled
off in terms of and particularly in the
in the Northeast that um um growth of
traffic volumes and and new drivers and
stuff has has slowed and uh longterm as
you mentioned the highway fund is
incrementally projected to um decline
based on uh increasing fuel efficiency
less travel and electric vehicles um and
we have had for a number of years you
know what we see is a structural deficit
in the in the highway fund the highway
fund Revenue has not been able to keep
up with um um operations and maintenance
costs from both us and the department of
safety so there have been a number of
one-time fixes over the past decade to
um help bail out the highway fund there
have been registration fee sir charges
um we had transferred some assets from
the from the turnpike system to the I
mean from the from the highway fund to
the turnpike system and used Turnpike
you know Revenue to buy those assets and
and and and help um um augment the
highway Fund in the last several years
there have been a number of um general
fund infusions into the um into the
highway fund to make to to make things
balanced so um again long-term stability
is one of those um one of one of those
issues and
concerns
um so that's a very highlevel brief
overview of the of the highway fund and
how it's utilized in the department and
that really comes to the uh end of end
of my presentation and if there are any
further questions we do have a a a chart
there um it kind it kind of talks about
but it shows the tradition it shows the
historical um Revenue history of of the
highway fund there for your reference
and um just my very last slide a couple
of the uh issues and challenges that
that we continue to work through I I
mentioned you know the workforce and the
vacancies we had a good discussion on
that um inflationary cost impacts are uh
affecting not just us but I think all
state a agencies and and and all
households as well too um one of the um
one of the things I like to point out
though is you know some of those
Workforce
vacancies uh and things do affect our
productivity um we are uh falling short
of targets that we would like to meet as
we prioritize resources to critical
areas uh we
prioritize um life safety um um efforts
and oftentimes at the expense of other
um maintenance needs particularly
preventative maintenance needs and that
can you know there somewhere down the
road those those um um preventative
maintenance the the lack of investment
of preventative maintenance you know
will will come due but um I like to say
that uh in and when we get to our budget
you'll probably hear me say it again we
are doing what we what we need to do
we're not getting done all that we would
like to do or feel that we should be
doing
but um we are getting done um what we
have to get done
so to the extent there any dedicated
funds beyond the big ones you talked
about here could you just get a list of
those too Mr Len and all you know
revenues coming in and the expenses
going out kind of thing sure do you know
what
um representative um public I just want
to make sure I understood your question
other so you got the highway fund you
talked about the ter pay fund um
Department of Safety had a whole bunch
of dedicated funds I don't know what the
situation is with with you all do you
have other smaller dedicated funds so
just a listing of the smaller dedicated
funds and what revenues flow into them
What expenses fall out of them what rsas
control them certainly right
representative Pap thank you Mr chair
and just to build on my last question
about the uh you know structural deficit
in the highway
fund whether you have an answer on this
right now or you answer later I'm happy
either way but in your opinion if we
look at it in terms of you know uh
Revenue per mile driven or per pound
mile driven whatever is the appropriate
measure do you feel that at this point
in time we are capturing revenue from
gas vehicles versus you know internal
combustion engine Vehicles versus
electric vehicles are those revenues
comparable or is one class of vehicles
paying more of a burden in the road tax
than the other as far as you can tell
and you know I would appreciate any
insight now or later yep I will I will
check I I don't have the numbers I know
last uh session maybe session before
last there was a um there was a
registration fee premium placed on EVs
and and hybrids um I've seen some of the
reports from the Department of Safety
it's it's generated a think around $2
million of of
Revenue I I know in the past we have
done studies and and representative M
nor Maes has had um um bills on a road
user fee where we had a lot of data that
that that compared what a fair share was
I don't know right off the bat how that
uh present um fee structure represents
to a fair share but we can but I can
check and we'll get you something thank
you I understand it's not a simple
question yeah that's why I'm asking it
very early so you have plenty of time to
uh you know get the best data available
and thank you appreciate that thank you
representative Murray thank you I have a
couple
questions you answered the bunch of them
already so thank you for that um some
years ago you were really struggling
with um repairs of plows and trucks and
stuff and they're I remember in pretty
frightening shape uh we worked really
hard to try to get you back on track to
purchasing new vehicles um even though
we don't know where we're going from
here um you know we're all facing some
difficulties with the revenues and the
budget um but to a certain extent can
you speak to are you on track now in
terms of Maintenance and um purchasing
of new materials for your plows and
trucks and all those things I would say
generally yes we have I I we have had
that has been a focus area and some past
budgets and we've put some um Capital
funds and and and others in in there and
in the our last budget that um
um uh Fleet investment cycle was was
recognized and more or less fully funded
so I think we are on a on a on a on a
good track there of keeping up we have
been hampered more by supply chain
issues than than actual funding issues
we've had we've had money and and
purchase orders and stuff out there that
that uh dealers and suppliers couldn't
couldn't meet with uh you know some of
the issues in the past years with with
that but um it will be a um it will be a
point of discussion in our upcoming
budget whether we can sustain that
recommended investment um
um replacement cycle for the for the
fleet I'm glad to hear you know where
you are for now um last year or last
budget cycle uh there was a line in the
budget pertaining to um public
transportation affecting Upper Valley
nashwa the Sea Coast trans yeah Transit
um that apparently did not make it into
the efficiency budget can you speak to
that is it in a priority budget or what
happened to um that line to that that
funding I I think we had talked about a
little bit with the with the with the
transit match when we were on the bureau
uh division of Aeronautics Rail and
Transit and the match requirement so the
state has had
historically um put very little to help
and assist um um local Transit agencies
with the operating match um some nominal
amount of about $200,000 a year which
was an un budget last last year last
budget session with um um um lobbying
from from the transit interest support
from the Department as well as
recognition that um there had been
additional investment there had been
additional um federal funds through FTA
in the on the on the federal funding
side that warranted uh you know some
consideration of additional State
assistance for the state match um under
hb2 um they infused about one point in
in the banum I think it's about $1.9
million of of General funds to um um
augment or or to go to local trans to
assist with local Transit match this
budget I I and the only reason I point
that out that it came from it was never
it never came through our budget so when
we started our budget this year basing
against the adjusted authorized you know
we did not have a um uh that that wasn't
reflected in our in our budget so when
we were given you know um relatively uh
level budget targets it wasn't able to
be accommodated within our budget but
yeah thank you um can you speak to your
collaboration with department
environmental services around Coastal
resilience because that's cost everybody
a lot of money in terms of storm damage
and
repairs
um in in general I mean I think in
general we work very closely with with
Department of Environmental Services the
uh Coastal risks and Hazard committee uh
commission that that was established by
legislature and has done a lot of work
on sea level change and stuff we sit on
that commission along with with da Dees
we utilize that uh scientific data and
that information in all of our project
planning um when we when we had we we're
doing a major Bridge Project over uh
over Hampton Harbor and part of the um
um setting of The elevations of the
peers and the abutments and the height
of the bridge were were were based on
the coastal risks and Hazard commissions
um recommended um planning sea level
elevations and things like that so um
permitting wise we we coordinate closely
with with uh Dees um we meet regularly
we have quarterly um executive office
meeting to make sure that things are
being coordinated um I I know that's
what you're getting at but I think I'm
I'm more concerned of when there's an
extreme weather event that causes damage
how does that throw off your budget what
does that do to you
financially
um yeah uh depending on the on the on
the size and scope so the the LA last
winter we had a a lot of damage along
the along the seaw wall along the
revetments along um 1A along along code
so we have um we have um um put State
forces State funds into repairing those
um there are longer term um repairs that
are needed we are pursuing um um thema
eligible Grant activity we did just get
a uh last spring we got a um $20 million
um Federal Highway Grant to support the
um rebuilding of those revetments but it
is an ongoing if if you've been out
there we've had we've had State forces
and contractors continuing all all
summer and all all this past winter um
at least rebuilding to the existing
levels um you know and uh uh Shoring up
the the sea defenses so it's been it is
an it is an unbudgeted impact that we
have to um absorb we seek to defay those
costs through um through FEMA or other
emergency relief funds but um we carry
those do you have anything more so if
there is a declaration then we can go uh
with FEMA funds or also um fhwa
emergency relief funds so those are
options um the timing of the funding is
interesting because it will take some
time to get those funds in the meantime
we do the work um and and use State
funds in the
meantime for I guess perhaps the future
I've been curious if we did not rely on
the tax credit for these match how much
more could we do um I don't know if you
can come up with a scenario or a
narrative to say you know if we didn't
rely on this so that we end up with you
know less impact of the money um what
else how much more could we have done
but I expect you know if you can come
back with that if that's sort of a
future question if that's not easy for
you to address some of I have some of
that so I can tell you that I can tell
you what we've earned and what we we
generally use and it's usually a one for
one and so we use approximately in in 24
we used 58 million um toll credits so
that's 58
million dollar of funding that that
elsewhere I hope this has been helpful I
hope we could answer your questions I
know um I I know hopefully you guys took
some notes of the questions we'll get
the information and stuff that you
requested we look forward to uh further
work with division 2 here so yeah this
been great thank you very much I
appreciate it thank you hopefully it was
informative very informative okay
especially for me good some new to this
thank you nice to meet you both nice to
meet
you and it's uh
3:44 I'm a little over I'm sorry about
that no no no you were fantastic I
appreciate you staying around it it was